- Guys, if you didn't know,
we are touring America!
(all cheering)
America!
- So, you guys already know we did like,
a quick little announcement
earlier in the month,
but we're here to tell you guys right now
that tickets are officially on sale.
You guys can go
get them right now,
- Woo!
- by going to
- Oh my God.
- the trashtastetour.com.
Link's in the description.
Here are all the places we're going to.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, I love that.
- Look at them.
- All of these places!
- There's so many,
we don't even wanna name 'em out.
Just pause and find your city.
- We're gonna have a year's worth
of trashing America content
just from this one tour.
- There's different tiers
of tickets available,
so if you wanna make sure you are one
of the first people to get
them, and before they sell out,
go now, smash the link in
subscription down below
to get your tickets
before they all sell out
'cause I mean, quite frankly,
I mean, who isn't gonna wanna come see us?
I mean, I'm so important.
(Garnt laughing)
- So guys, again, head on over
to the trashtastetour.com.
Link's in description below
and for all of you Americans,
we will see you all there.
- Yes.
- On with the episode.
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- Hi, everyone, welcome
to "Trash Taste Podcast,"
including your special
guest me, LilyPichu.
- Wow.
- We're joined
by our three hosts...
(guys laughing)
- This has never happened.
- Is that the intro
we're gonna use?
- This has never happened before.
- I'm just joking.
(mellow music)
- What's up xenophobic xylophones?
Welcome back to another episode
of the "Trash Taste Podcast."
That's your fault.
- Yeah (laughs).
- That is your fault.
- Xylophones.
- Yep,
all you xenophobic xylophones
out there, shout out to you.
I'm your host, Joey, with
the boys, Connor and Garnt,
and she's already done it,
but we have LilyPichu on the podcast.
- Yeah, she just took over our podcast.
I don't think that's ever happened.
- Yeah, no.
- This is like Ladybeard
I think where someone just
took over the intro (chuckles).
- So yeah, welcome.
- Oh, can I put a disclaimer?
- Yeah.
- I just recently got gum surgery,
so I have like, shit all over my teeth.
So if I like show it,
- Oh.
- please don't be freaked out.
- Okay.
- That's all.
- Good, good.
- People in comments are like,
"What's that on your teeth?
(all laughing) Does she
have gum on her teeth?"
I'm like, no, it's Chapstick.
- Well, I guess for what-
- So, anime.
- (laughs) You're jumping
- Oh my God.
- right into it?
- Lily's just like,
- Okay.
- dying to talk about anime.
- Yeah.
- Anime.
Well, I used to have an anime podcast.
- [Guys] Yeah.
- And that didn't last very long
'cause talking about anime,
only anime in a podcast was like, not...
(Joey laughs)
- That's literally the
problem that we've up with.
- Yeah, why do you think we don't do that?
- Yeah, we started off
as an anime podcast.
Although, not really 'cause
we had like one episode
to do with anime and then we just gave up.
- It was like half an episode.
- It was a half an episode.
- But there's only so many
things you could talk about it.
What's your favorite anime?
What are you watching this season?
Like, what do you think about...
And then it's just like,
well, what do we talk about?
- [Guys] Yeah.
- I mean, that's what I
think the biggest problem
with every anime creator,
which is you just run out
of anime to talk about
'cause there's only a few certain topics
that people really want to hear about.
- Yes.
- And then everyone
just gets bored of you,
- Yep.
- like everyone's favorite anime
is kinda like the same thing
most of the time.
- Yep.
- It hasn't changed.
Mine hasn't changed in like,
well now I don't know, okay.
"Arcane's" not an anime, but it-
- Yes, it is.
- "Arcane" is-
- No, it's not.
- It is totally an anime.
- We love "Arcane"
- Yeah, yeah.
- but Joey refuses to watch it.
- Why?
- Can we talk about "Arcane?"
Do you wanna talk about "Arcane?"
- No!
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- Why, why won't he watch it?
- Stop!
- He's a contrarian, he won't
watch anything that's popular.
- Oh, because it's too popular for him?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because people keep hyping it up,
and so the expectations
are just insane for me now.
- It'll meet your expectations.
(Garnt laughs)
(Connor laughs)
- [Connor] You have heard her.
- I've heard so many shows
that with the exact same thing
and it hasn't lived up to the expectation.
So, I'm scared now to watch it.
- I'm on team Lily with this one.
I think you will.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt and Lily] It's really good.
- You know what?
If it helps you, you can
watch it Japanese dub.
(guys laughing)
- That's not the issue.
- There's a-
- That's not the...
- It's really cute.
Like, there's a part where
Vi calls Caitlyn the cupcake.
- Yeah.
- And they like,
they did it in every single language
'cause it's a really hot scene.
Sorry, spoilers.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And then he's like, "Cupcake."
It's like really like-
- Yeah.
I've seen the Japanese dubs of that scene,
and it's better than
- Right? It's hot.
- the English dubs.
It is fuckin' hot.
- It's hot.
- It is hot, oh my God.
- Okay,
so maybe you would like that.
- Maybe.
- Like, watch it is Japanese.
I mean, you can pretend it's anime.
- Yeah.
- Pretend it's anime, yeah.
Even Connor refuses to
not call it anything else.
- Wait, what?
- You're like, "It's an anime."
- Yeah, it is an anime.
- But maybe we should
say it's not an anime.
- I just do that to annoy
people like (sputtering).
"Just stop saying," you know?
- Oh, I understand, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They get very frustrated.
- Same vibe
is calling "Avatar" an anime.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I just think
it's like dumb-
- Oh, "Avatar's" coming out
with a movie, did you see that?
- Yeah.
- I did not.
- I'm so excited.
- Are you excited?
I'm like, kinda scared.
- Like, is it three live action movies
or three animated movies?
- It looks
like animated movies.
- I think it's animated.
- Animated movies, okay.
- Yeah.
- Pretty excited because
you guys like "Avatar?"
- Yeah, I love "Avatar."
- I love "Avatar."
- I actually haven't seen "Avatar" yet.
(Joey gasps)
- What?
- I know, I know,
I know.
- Don't worry.
The high expectations you have, it'll hit.
(all laughing)
- It actually does hit.
- It actually does.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How does it feel?
- It's not like an "Arcane,"
you would watch.
- The first season's really slow
but you do need to watch it to set up
for like the second and third-
- Yeah, I think I watched the first season
and I thought the first
season was a little slow,
but then I heard it gets better
and then I just, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I never continued it after
the first season.
- Yeah, it gets better.
You just got like, push.
- But "Arcane" doesn't have
that. It's just win, win, win.
Like, it's just great.
- Yeah.
- "Arcane" from like, episode one,
fuckin' incredible.
- Yeah.
- "Arcane" is insane.
- Joey wants to die right now.
- You're depriving yourself.
- Yeah.
- It's been 0 days since
"Arcane" was mentioned.
(guys laughing)
- You really should watch it.
There's only nine episodes out.
Like, what's your excuse?
I don't understand.
- What are you,
the comments section?
(all laughing)
I'm aware.
- This is great content.
- I'm aware.
- You should watch it. Okay.
- Okay, I will, I will.
- I love all this anime talk.
- Yeah.
- "Arcane," "Avatar."
- Such great anime.
- Nothing but anime.
- I love-
- Okay, question since
you're an "Avatar" fan.
- Okay.
- "Legend of Korra," do you rate it?
- I think if they were
told that they could
have more than one season,
'cause I heard they were like-
- They were meddled a lot, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah, I think.
- I think it could have
been so much better.
But I think there's some
good parts in "Korra," like.
- Yeah, I liked the first season.
- [Lily and Joey] Yeah.
- And then I found the ending was kind of-
- Rushed almost.
- Yeah.
It was kinda like, okay, all right.
- Spoilers, does it matter?
- No, it doesn't matter.
- No.
- I mean, I haven't seen
it, but it doesn't really
matter too much.
- Oh, do you guys look
at spoilers before you watch something?
- Never.
- No.
- Why would we do that?
- Oh, neither do I.
- What the, what?
- Your attitude.
You do do that.
I remember now!
Last time, I'm getting like fuckin'-
- It did sound like you do,
and then you said you're like, "Nah."
- I was getting like
fuckin' Vietnam flashbacks
like the last time we recorded
an anime podcast together.
- Yes, mm hm.
- And you said you read spoilers
before you watch the show.
- What?
- So, it's the journey
- Like how-
- not the destination.
I am a firm believer of like,
if I know what happens it doesn't detract
from my viewing experience
because either way I'm watching it.
- But why not have the
experience of like say,
being able to watch it-
- It's just the anxiety.
- But then you...
It's not knowing what's gonna happen.
- Yeah, the anxiety.
- No, but-
- Do you get anxiety reading
the spoilers as it's going on?
- No, but, well, sometimes,
but like, when I read
the spoilers I'm like,
"Oh, well, that's how it ends,
or that's how the conflict is resolved.
I feel much better, let me
enjoy it and watch this now,"
you know what I mean?
- But you already know what it's gonna
be before you watch it.
- Yeah, but that's-
- This is like,
divorced parent attitudes.
I just wish I could know
when they'd stop fighting.
When will they like, I just wanna know.
- If I had a crystal ball
that could literally tell
me anything I wanted to
know, I would take it.
Like, I wanna know when I die, how I die,
when my dog's gonna die, like when, like-
- Why do you know what?
- So I could treasure
every day before that day.
- You're not going to otherwise?
You're like, "Nah, that's all right."
- I don't know when
- Kick 'em in the head.
- they're gonna die,
so I'm just gonna like,
piss my life away whatever.
- I still would, I just, it's
nice, the information is nice.
What would have happened if I like,
went this route in my
career or this, whatever?
Like, I wanna know everything.
- Wouldn't you like let...
Let's say if like, life,
this crystal ball told you
that you were gonna fail,
- Yeah.
- you'd be like, "Well,
why am I trying then?"
- Right? Then I'd just die.
- What if you failed
- Wouldn't life be boring
- because you saw the crystal-
- in that case if you
just knew everything
that was going to happen?
Because everything's
pre-determined in that case.
- Yeah, but I could still
experience it, right?
Just because I know like,
oh, I'm going to drink
a lot here and have fun,
but I'm still gonna drink and have fun.
That's not gonna...
- (laughs) So, you don't like
surprises is what I'm hearing.
- Yeah, I guess.
I just like knowing stuff.
It's anxiety, I don't know.
There was one time we went
to watch a scary movie.
- Yeah.
- Mm hm.
- And I just, I could not take it.
I wanted to take out my phone and read
the spoilers like in the movie theater.
- Okay.
- In the cinemas.
- Okay, actually I was going to say,
there is one case where I do
just read and watch spoilers.
- Yeah.
- Horror movies?
- Horror movies.
- Right!
It's kinda like that.
- Because okay, I'm a fuckin' pussy
when it comes to horror
movies, I'll be honest.
Like, I hate not knowing
what's going to happen.
- [Lily] Who's gonna die.
- But like, at the same time I think
a lotta horror movie concepts
are just really fuckin' interesting.
So, I like,
- Yeah, they are.
- So, I watch more videos breaking
down horror movie spoilers
than I actually watch horror movies.
- [Lily] Oh my God.
- Sydney's gonna fuckin' kill me
because she fuckin' loves horror movies,
but I think I know like,
most horror movies,
like, the plot of most
big horror movies now.
- I think I get what you mean.
Like, I've seen arduous amounts of like,
would you be able to survive
this "Saw" trap video
more than the actual "Saw" movie.
- Right?
- Like, I haven't seen
a single "Saw" movie but God damn,
I wanna know how you escape from that.
- Right, 'cause like horror movies
have some of the best
hooks of like, any films.
- Yeah.
- Like, you can boil
it down to like one tag line or one like,
it's basically a YouTube clickbait.
It's got like the
interesting concept but like,
I don't want to experience like,
the bullshit of getting
scared, getting jump scared.
- Right.
- And all that shit.
- Oh, that reminds me of
my other favorite anime,
you know movie recaps on YouTube?
- Yeah.
- Mm hm.
- I watch that so much.
Like, I don't even watch movies anymore.
I watch movie recaps.
- You have the same brain at Garnt.
Garnt does the exact same thing.
What-
- "Hello there.
Mystery Recapped here. Today
I'm going to tell you a story
about blah, blah, blah, blah.
Watch on to take-"
- Is that the dude's voice?
- No, I just like your accents.
(all laughing)
- Okay. I was just like, is
this like an action video?
- I've never related to someone so hard.
I thought I was a psychopath.
- It's really, you guys should try it.
It's good bedtime stories.
You just put one on and
then you just like...
You listen to someone
explain the movie plot.
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- You don't need to spend
two hours watching the movie.
- No, I totally get that with movies that-
- This is why art is dead.
Like-
(Garnt laughing)
(Connor laughing)
- [Joey] No, I totally-
- This is why I watch
YouTube videos at 1.5 speed.
You don't need-
- I do that, 1.5.
I cannot do one speed only.
Go on.
- What?
- Dang, that's psychopathic.
(all laughing)
But like no, I totally get that
with like movies that are
say, like really fucked up
or it's like all really shit for example.
It's like yeah, okay,
I'll watch a guy breaking down a movie,
but if it's like, do you
do that with all movies,
even ones you look at and you're like,
oh, that looks interesting.
- No, not all movies.
- Not all of 'em.
- Yeah, most movies are like,
I think in the let's say, the six to seven
outta 10 range.
- So in other words,
if it's a Marvel movie
you're gonna watch it?
- Depends on the Marvel movie.
- I would watch Marvel.
I love Marvel.
- What the hell, dude?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's my favorite anime.
- I love that anime.
- Yeah. (all laughing)
But like sometimes I have
certain Marvel movies
that I wanna watch and
experience to the fullest,
but like I don't wanna watch
all the bullshit that comes before it.
Like, for example when I'm
going to watch "Doctor Strange"
I don't wanna fucking
watch "Wanda Vision."
I'll just watch someone's
summary of "Wanda Vision."
- Okay, but "Wanda Vision"
is not a bad TV show.
- Is it not?
- I think you should watch it.
The ending's a little
weak but I think it's-
- Did you watch the new
"Doctor Strange" movie?
- I did.
- Did you like it?
- Okay, so there were so many
elements that I really liked.
The horror elements were like, fantastic.
And then there was some
really cheesy lines.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I didn't like it.
- There was some really cheesy lines.
- I've actually spoiled myself
on the "Doctor Strange" movie
because of this guy, actually.
- Have you guys watch "Everything
Everywhere All At Once?"
- Yeah, that movie's so good.
- So good.
- No, no, no.
- Oh!
- I really want to-
- That's not something I'm
going to spoil for myself.
That's like a-
- I have a...
That's the one movie I
didn't spoil myself on.
- Yeah, because like I have-
- Did you watch it?
- I did.
- It was so good, right?
- It's amazing.
- Okay, okay.
- 'Cause I have like, certain
movies where I'm like,
I wanna experience this to the fullest.
- Yes, yes.
- I want to not spoil myself,
and then some of them I'm
just like, eh, whatever.
I just wanna know what happens.
Like-
- "Morbius?"
- Yeah, like when you say
"Doctor Strange" was like mid,
I was like, okay, well-
- You can spoil that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I really-
- No, "Morbius" is a
perfect example of like,
I'll just go and watch a recap.
- Yeah.
- Because like, I'm not gonna
go fuckin' watch the movie.
- I'm not either.
I'm not even gonna watch a
fuckin' recap of "Morbius."
(all laughing)
- I only watch the recap so I
can understand the memes more.
- I really thought they said
"It's Morbin' time" in the movie.
- Yeah, I thought so too.
They don't even say it.
- I thought so as well.
- Yeah.
- I thought that was an actual line
that people were memeing.
- For the longest time I thought,
"Oh, it's just a line in the movie."
It's just that bad.
- "Morbin' time,"
I really thought.
- I just love the idea of just memeing
these really terrible movies and giving,
like the executive is like saying,
"Well, people love this movie.
Everyone's talkin' about it."
- If they don't say "It's Morbin' time"
in "Morbius 2" I'll be
thoroughly disappointed.
- Direct to TV, right?
It's direct to Apple TV+.
- Is it?
- It's not going in,
- Oh my God (laughs).
- like, it's not a cinematic release.
I think it's a release.
- Oh my God.
- Well, no, it did get
a cinematic release.
- Sorry, no, no, the second movie
is not going to be a theatrical.
- There's gonna be a second one?
- Yeah, so it was
green lighted.
- Yeah, they're making
a second one.
- Oh.
- Why would they do that? Why-
- 'Cause it was so popular.
- Yeah, but-
- Look at Google Trends.
It was doing so well.
- But like, didn't they like,
who produced it again, Sony?
I think it was Sony
- Yeah, that's right.
- that produced it.
- Yeah.
- Didn't they like, re-release
it because of the memes
in cinemas?
- Yeah, they did, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then it fucking bombed.
(all laughing)
They were like, "People wanna see this
because everyone's talking about it.
Let's re-release it."
Fucking bombs, like.
(Lily speaking faintly)
So, I'm surprised they're
doing a second one, honestly.
- I don't know how it's gonna work.
I don't-
- It's not.
That's the thing, it's not.
- The first one didn't work.
- Yeah, how do you top the first one?
Oh my God.
- So, have you ever read like,
a spoiler to a TV show or a movie
and you've kind of like, regretted it?
Has that ever happened?
- No.
- Never?
- What?
- Like, literally never.
I just enjoy media differently.
Oh my gosh, you guys's accent
reminds me of "Harry Potter."
I think "Harry Potter"-
- He's Australian (laughs)!
- I'm not even British (laughs).
- I'm sorry, I just
wanted to segue into like,
I think "Harry Potter" should be an anime.
- Yeah, I mean, so what
makes you think this?
- I mean, did you watch
"Little Witch Academia?"
That's basically "Harry Potter."
- I like the-
- Yeah, that's true.
- What? Eh, no that's not.
- But I thought-
- It's "Harry Potter" with
little girls, that's all it is.
- I don't know.
- I mean,
it's got the vibe down but it's
not exactly "Harry Potter."
It's more cutesie than "Harry
Potter," obviously, obviously.
- Yeah, obviously.
- Have we all watched "Harry Potter?"
- There's so many that could
be animes but they're not.
- Yeah, we've all watched "Harry Potter."
I haven't watched all of them.
- What do you mean you
haven't watched all of them?
- I got up to "Goblet of Fire."
- What the fuck?
So you haven't watched "Harry Potter."
- I've seen half of 'em.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so I've watched
up to "Goblet of Fire,"
and then I skipped to the last movie.
- What?
(guys laughing)
How do you even have your citizenship?
A case study.
What the hell?
- No, 'cause to me like,
I was never that obsessed
with "Harry Potter."
- Oh.
- I saw it as,
I've met more Americans that are like,
really into "Harry Potter"
than I have Brits.
- It's like an entire generation.
- [All] Yeah.
- I like, you know what
in "Avatar" it's like,
"Oh, what element are you?"
- Yeah.
- "Harry Potter,"
what house are you?
Like, I like things like that.
I like to compartmentalize my friends
into categories in my brain.
So, like what element are you?
- So, we're just
the British guys I guess.
- Element?
- Yeah, like, in "Avatar"
like what element are you?
- I don't know, like, "Harry
Potter" I'm a Slytherin.
- Oh, in "Harry Potter" I'm a Hufflepuff.
- Everyone's a Hufflepuff,
everyone's a Hufflepuff.
- How'd you know
what house you are?
- A quiz.
- There's a official quiz
you can do.
- Oh, is there?
- Yeah.
- I haven't done that.
How has everyone
done this quiz.
- Like a personality quiz.
Because everyone knows at least
one over fuckin' enthusiastic
"Harry Potter" fan.
- Yeah.
- Oh, a person that...
Oh my gosh, guys.
What MBTI type are you?
(guys laughing)
I'll get into astrology next if you want,
but what MBTI type are-
- No.
- Do you know?
- I don't know the code,
but I know the name.
- [Lily] What is it?
- Executive Assertive or something.
I don't know.
- I don't know.
- Meilyne, what am I?
Because you made me do that test.
- I'm in a-
- Connor's a ESTP.
Hold up.
- ESTP.
- I'm something with an I, I remember.
- There's an E in there.
- Yeah.
- EIPT, I guess, I don't know.
- EI, what?
- PTSD.
- I'm ESTP?
- HTML.
- What is ESTP? I-
- I've never even heard
of that, I'ma be honest.
- ESPN.
- It's the one with 16, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, it was,
I don't fuckin' know.
Maybe-
- ESPN.
- [ Meilyne] You're ENTJ.
ENTJ.
- Who's that?
- Which one was that?
- [ Meilyne] ENTJ.
- Dude, you wanna explain what this?
'Cause I think a lot of our audience
might not know what-
- Oh, I don't know shit.
I just like asking this.
- It's like-
- Do you know yours?
- INFP.
- INFP, is that like the artsy one?
- Yeah.
- I think so.
Because there was one with
like a woman with butterflies.
- That's it.
- And I'm like, oh!
- That's it!
- That might be
my one as well.
That sounds familiar.
- INFT.
- Yeah.
- Maybe.
- I had an I in mine.
- Mine was a woman who
looked stern with like, wood.
So, I don't know what that says about me.
- [Lily] That's funny.
- You're stern.
- I guess so.
- But explain what this
is 'cause I'm like,
I'm sure a lot of our
audience are lost right now.
"They're just saying letters."
- No, no, everyone knows this.
- "They're just
saying letters right now."
- It's a fun personality test.
- Yeah.
- It's not anything serious.
- It's just fun to talk about.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Meilyne I think asked
us all to do it, though.
- Yeah.
- It's like 16
questions is it?
- No, no, no, no, no.
- There's 16 personalities.
- Yeah.
- 16 personalities.
- It's like astrology but
for psychology, I think.
- Yeah, that's pretty much it.
- Right?
- So, psychology?
(all laughing)
- Astrology for psychology.
- I think it's a fun like,
conversation starter sometimes.
- Yeah.
- Like, oh, you're this?
- It's a very rough way of kind of saying,
"I'm kind of like this."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is what
I would say I focus,
put my personality into.
- Yeah, I mean it makes
more sense than astrology
at least.
- Yeah.
- Because it has like, logical
steps to categorize you.
But it doesn't always mean
it's like 100% accurate.
- Well, I mean there's more
than 16 personalities out there.
I'm sure.
- Of course, yeah.
- So, that's it.
That's the cap.
It's really nice and neat.
- Yeah.
- We love that it's 16.
- It just doesn't make sense, really.
- No, I never, do you believe
in like, the astrology stuff?
- No.
- No?
- But it's funny.
- It's funny.
- Yeah.
- It is.
I think it's more fun than anything.
- But some of my friends are very into it.
- Yeah.
- I'm like,
"Oh, you're a Scorpio?
Yeah, you're a Scorpio Rising
and your Moon is Taurus,
that means like at this day,"
they're like super into it.
- I feel like it's just
an excuse for like,
women to be racist sometimes.
- Okay, that was like big jump.
Big jump.
- They're like, "I will not
associate with a Scorpio.
I will be dead."
- Astrology to racist.
(Connor laughs)
- It's like the highest form of classism.
- It is, it is.
(all laughing)
Think about it.
Whenever anybody actually
like, talks about it like,
"I cannot be near a Scorpio."
You're like, what's wrong with you?
- What are you?
- I'm a Leo.
- Oh, yeah, I could tell.
(all laughing)
- See what I mean?
It's so you can judge me.
- That is major Leo energy
coming from you right now.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- I can't believe it.
- I'm like, how?
Everyone born in July is just
this fuckin' weirdo who's like,
has fuckin' rulers and this-
- He's getting really
angry like a Leo would.
- Yeah, right.
- Sorry, sorry.
- He does get very angry.
- Well, do you know what you are?
- Yeah, I'm a Gemini.
- Gemini.
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah? Makes sense?
Yeah, yeah?
- I can see it.
- Can you give me any
information from that?
- You are definitely.
You, you're a Cancer.
- I'm a Libra.
- Libra. (all laughing)
- That's a great friend.
- Did I just hear that? (all laughing)
- We're still talking
about star signs, right?
- Yeah, we're talking
It's like, you are cancer.
- If you had watched "Arcane."
(all laughing)
- You should watch "Arcane," though.
- Yeah, thanks.
- I'm getting into that a lot, wow.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like traumatized by it.
- Yeah, because for like
about 10 weeks straight
we could just could not stop bringing
up "Arcane" after it launched.
- Because it's amazing.
- 'Cause it's so good, right?
- 'Cause you guys have watched it,
you know how good it is.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Exactly, and also we're
- You need to watch it.
- like, "League" players kind of.
- Yeah.
- Oh, you play "League?"
Oh, what rank are you guys?
- When I used to play I was Diamond 4.
- No, no, no, no, no, like now.
- I haven't played in like two years.
- Yeah.
- Oh, two years.
- I haven't played a lot.
- What are you, bronze?
- Oh!
- So (indistinct). No, I am-
- Silver now.
(all laughing)
I feel really bad sometimes
when people watch "Arcane"
and they're like, "Oh, wow I
wanna try "League of Legends."
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they go into game and
it's nothing like "Arcane."
- Yeah.
- It's like everything about "Arcane"
wants to get me to play "League" again.
I play one game and I'm reminded like,
why I stopped playing "League."
- I mean, the only thing
that's like accurate
between the game and the show is like,
there's racism between like,
the characters and stuff.
- [Lily] The characters, yeah.
- That's pretty accurate.
- It's a fantastic...
You don't even need to know about "League"
to enjoy the show.
- Yeah.
- We played "League" on the EU server,
and the EU server is, that's just awful.
- Oh, yeah, I heard.
- Is there a single good server?
- No, but like, Europe because obviously
you shove all the
European countries on one.
- [Lily] Every, yeah.
- And then everyone's like,
everyone just bullies French
people immediately and-
- Yeah.
- What does this stand for?
- That's GamerSupps.
- GamerSupps.
- Gamer Subs?
- Supps?
- GamerSupps.
- Yes.
- Oh, wow, that's cool.
I like the big titty
anime girls on the water.
- Right.
Givin' 'em a free shout out.
- God damn.
- So, actually we kinda like jumped ahead
'cause we're kinda like, jumped this way.
Normally what happens
when we have gusts on
is we have the guests introduce
themselves and what they do.
Just like-
- Oh, we were supposed
to do that? Right!
- Yeah.
Just in case our audience know what-
- But you were immediately
like, "What's you star sign?"
- "Watch "Arcane," Joey."
- Yeah, "Watch "Arcane."
- "You are Cancer."
(all laughing)
- So, should I introduce myself?
(all chattering)
- Yeah, what do you do?
Let people know.
- Yeah, hi, I'm LilyPichu.
I go, I um, I uh...
Can you just cut that?
- No, leave that in,
- Cut that.
- leave that in.
- You can leave that in.
- Hi, I'm LilyPichu.
I'm on YouTube.
I stream sometimes, I
voice act, I make music.
I like anime.
- So like, how would
you categorize yourself
as a content creator now?
Are you just like,
- I don't know.
- a bit of everything now?
- Yeah, I like to dabble in
a little bit of everything
but not excel in like one thing.
- (laughs) I feel that.
- Right.
(all laughing)
- I feel that.
- I feel like you've managed
to stay online and I guess,
always get more and more
popular and relevant as you go.
- Yeah.
- No, I think it's a...
- [Connor] Well, I mean,
generally you have.
- I'm in a bit
of a dip right now but.
(all chattering)
- You've done so well.
- Yeah, but like you've
been on the internet
and you've been in like,
the content creation space
for like so fucking long.
- Too long.
- So long.
- Like, when did you start?
What year was it?
- Literally like, I feel
like over 10 years ago.
Like, I was like 19 or something.
I made like, well, I
started voicing cartoons-
- Anime, you did fandubs, right?
- Anime, stuff like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's right.
- Me too, me too.
- Yeah, I think a lotta
people start with fandubs.
Those early YouTube fandub
days were like interesting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause were you part
of like the VAA crowds back in the day
when everyone was like,
- Yeah,
- fandubbing?
- everyone wanted to fandub
and voice act.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I really did wanna voice act though,
so I never gave up on that dream,
and thankfully got some roles.
- Hell yeah, hell yeah.
- Thank you, "Genshin Impact," thank you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's how I started.
(all laughing)
- Sick.
- That's such a long journey,
and so like, so how did you like,
transition from just doing anime stuff
and then you started like,
streaming and then you got
into Offline TV.
- Yeah.
- How did like, that happen?
- Oh my gosh, like how did it happen?
Like, I just started making videos.
Like, people liked them
and they started making,
and once you get more clout and viewers,
you connect with other
people in the industry easier
as you guys know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Offline TV was like, you know Scarra?
- Yes, of course.
- Yeah.
- Wanted me in it and he was like,
"No, there's no way we can get it."
It was really cute and he was like real,
he was all (indistinct) and shy and shit,
but like, I love Scarra.
- Yeah.
- He invited me,
so I went on.
I think honestly, a lot of why my career
has not died yet is because
like, the connections.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it's really hard for one person
to do everything by themselves.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like,
either way popularity fades.
- Right.
- Like, looks fade.
Whatever made you popular fades.
Like, new trends come.
If you can't stay on top of
it, you're gonna fall behind.
- Yeah.
- So like,
definitely being on Offline TV and like,
connecting with other people,
collabing helps a lot.
- Yeah.
- Like, I would like
to, like, for example,
when the pandemic started,
remember the whole "Among Us" craze?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course,
of course.
- That shit like,
made so many people's careers.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I remember like, Corpse
Husband especially.
Like, Corpse Husband went
- Yeah!
- from like, I have never
heard of this person before-
- He's like a super star now.
- Yeah, to like K-pop level
of popularity.
- He went from
reading Creepypastas to
like selling multi platinum.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Like, how the fuck
do you that?
- That's insane.
- And Michael like, likes
to listen to Creepypasta
before he goes to sleep.
He used to listen to Corpse Husband.
- No way.
- Yeah.
- And now Corpse is like...
- Like a star.
- Star.
- Yeah.
- That's insane to me.
- Like the super star right now
especially in the content creation space.
- God.
- Yeah.
It's like you never
know who's gonna pop off
and who's gonna like, fall of.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's very volatile, it's scary.
- I mean, it is,
but I guess that's just
part of like the career
that we've chosen, right?
- Oh, yeah.
- It's scary.
You wake up and you don't know
if you're gonna have a career next year.
- No-
- One year is like,
such a long fuckin' time in YouTube space.
Which is why I find it impressive
when anyone can be around for like,
as long as you for example.
- I'm like a dinosaur in YouTube years.
- [Connor] You've been around for awhile.
- I'm feelin' that, okay?
- You say that.
Like, "I feel that."
- When did you start?
- 2007.
- Wow!
Wow.
Well, yeah, you're a dinosaur.
- Yeah, I am, I am.
- Well, if you ever like,
watched anime back in the day,
you just like, recognize his voice,
'cause you were like,
- What were you again?
- That's the Garnt
- Weren't you like,
- who did the movies.
- the fourth ever Anitube?
- I was like, the fourth Anitube worker.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- YouTube should give you like a little,
you know those like
plaques when you get 100K?
Anituber.
- Yeah.
- No, they should not, no.
No, don't give them that.
- We don't need that.
- I think anime
YouTubers deserve it.
- He didn't even get a Silver Play Button.
- No I didn't because I got 100K
I think before they started
sending off Silver Play Buttons.
So, I just never got them.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- That's impressive.
I do think anyone who's been on the space
for like that long,
you gotta be getting something, right?
- Yeah.
- Luck can only take you so far, so.
- So, when I started doing YouTube,
it was 'cause I was getting
annoyed with voice acting.
I was like, I don't wanna
fucking keep fandubbing
other people's stuff.
- Right.
- I don't know if you
were the same kinda thing,
you're like-
- I'm sure we've
all reached that point.
- Yeah.
'Cause you're like, I'm
just tired of everyone
taking their time.
- I wanna do my own thing.
- Yeah, everyone's like,
they've taken so long.
You audition for something, they're like,
"You got the part," and then they're like,
they never do anything or
they make you record stuff
and then you don't do it.
Was that like a similar thing for you?
Were you like, I'm tired
of waiting another-
- A lot of unfinished projects, yeah.
Eventually you get tired
and you wanna like,
do your own thing but.
- Yeah, yeah.
It was same for me.
- Yeah.
Yep, so you talked
about Offline TV before,
and how that started.
So, were you there right at the beginning?
- Near the beginning, yes.
- Are you allowed to talk about
like, how that forms at all?
- Well, back then it was like,
Chris who's no longer with us,
Scarra, Pocky, (indistinct)
who's no longer with us,
Pocky I think,
they just wanted to make
like a content creator group.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And it was like, they
invited me to live with them.
- Right.
- I thought it was like,
really weird at first but like-
(all laughing)
At that time I'd just
broken up with my boyfriend
and I was in like a really bad place,
and they were like, "Come live with us."
So, I lived with them and they're like,
"All right, wake up at five a.m.
We're going boxing and we're
gonna make it into a video."
And I'm like, what?
It started out as a group of friends
who just wanted to make cool videos.
- [Guys] Yeah.
- And eventually that like,
expanded to what it is now.
I think even today we
have trouble separating
the friends from the business,
'cause if you start off as friends,
but you wanna make it a business,
like a full time organization,
you're gonna hurt some feelings.
- Right.
- It's impossible
for everyone, huh?
- I think that's why
we feel lucky that it's
just the three of us,
'cause I feel like when it
gets to like a large group,
it's always hard to manage
everyone equally, right?
- You're not gonna make everyone happy.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- How was it living in a house with like,
I guess, your best friends
making content together?
Does that make it like,
harder to separate friendship
for business?
- Oh yeah.
It was always intertwined.
- Right.
- We could not separate it,
but it was funny because we would pop
into each other's streams
whenever we wanted.
It was easy to like, collaborate.
It was nice.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I imagine always having
to be like on is probably tiring.
- Sometimes, but it's also like,
we liked each other so
it wasn't that hard.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Was it easy
to like hang out as just like,
a group of friends without
feeling pressure to like say,
make content about it or make
something out of it?
- Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
- Okay, that's good.
- I did get closer
to a lot of people.
- This episode is
sponsored by PayPal Honey.
- The easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer.
- Gentlemen, we're a
bunch of Zoomers, right?
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- At least we'd like to think we are,
and we all shop online.
But doesn't it suck
when you're at checkout
and that promo code field
is just taunting you?
Thanks to Honey, manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past.
Honey's the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one
it finds to your cart.
- So good.
- Woo!
- [Joey] Imagine you're shopping
at one of your favorite websites,
when you're at the checkout,
the Honey button appears
and all you have to do
is click Apply Coupons,
wait a few seconds as
Honey searches for coupons
that works for that site,
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch as the prices drop.
- So guys, we've been in America
for about two, three weeks now.
What has money saved you money on?
- Well, when I came here I was missing
a lot of stuff to do my stream setup,
and I saved a bunch of stuff
on different wires, cables,
everything I needed thanks to Honey.
- If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight
missing out on savings,
and by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a favor,
and supporting us too.
So, what are you waiting for?
Go to-
- joinhoney.com.
- /trashtaste.
That's-
- joinhoney.com.
- /trashtaste.
- Back to the episode.
- I did hentai voice
acting with you, right?
- Yeah, you did, yeah.
- That was fun.
- I think you've done a few things.
- I thought that was the only
thing I really did with you.
- Wait, hold on, do you wanna
explain that real quick?
- So, I did this video series
where I used to take
like notoriously famous,
like bad clips and I was like,
let's see if like, we just
fix only the voice acting,
will it like prove that's the-
- Oh, is that the one
I did with you as well?
- I think you've done it,
yeah you did it as well.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause a lot of the time,
people have this notion about like shows
that are bad voice acting and it's like,
it's definitely the voice acting,
and it's like well, all right,
well, let's get good voice actors
to do the exact same
script with the same music
and all that and prove that 99%
of the time it's like, everything else.
And of course, if you throw actors into
a bad script or terrible animation,
it's not the actor's fault.
- So, I wanted to do that.
- Yeah.
- And so, I got Lily to
fix some hentai clips.
- That was fun.
- Yeah.
- I liked that.
- He was like, "You
wanna voice some hentai?"
I'm like, "Fuck yeah, let's go."
That was fun as fuck.
- Back when Connor did
voice acting content, right?
- Yeah, I don't do that anymore.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Really? You should.
Why not? Voice acting's fun.
- Try to like, think of how you can kind
of expand it and kind of
make it into more content.
- That is hard.
- I feel like at least
right now I'm like there's nothing
that I can think of
that's like, a great idea.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- I definitely got as much out of it
as I think I can for now.
I don't know, we'll see.
- I see, I see.
- Also, that fixing voice act series,
I could tell you spend
a lotta time on that.
- Oh, those were,
that's a long time to-
- Yeah.
(Connor speaking indistinctly)
'Cause I think the biggest thing
is just scheduling that many people
in that many time zones.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember when I like,
used to do "Abridged" series.
Like, it was fun up until I had
to like fuckin' schedule
recording sessions
with everyone which was just,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- like the biggest pain in the ass.
- [Lily] Yeah.
- And I mean, I would do all the voices
if I really felt comfortable,
but I'm like, I'm British
and a lotta the times,
I don't wanna do an American voice either.
- Can you do an American voice?
- (laughs) On command I don't want to.
- Okay, like-
- I've done American
for movies and stuff as well.
- Try it.
Okay, we're gonna do a scene, okay?
- No, no, no, no, no, no (laughs).
- Set up the scene.
- All right.
- Hi, welcome to Starbucks,
how can I help you?
- Um, um, hi.
(all laughing)
Can I get a coffee?
- "Hi!
Hi!"
- Can I get an Americano, please?
- Americano, is that all you're gonna get?
- Fine, no.
- Do you have
a point system with us?
- No, fuck.
(all laughing)
I have crippling anxiety.
- End scene.
- Oh, hi there, my name's Markiplier.
(all laughing)
Can you just give me a coffee?
- I kinda realized you just
did a Markiplier impression.
- Yeah, whenever I do it, I'm like-
- Yeah, he did it very nice.
- Whenever anyone's like,
"Do an American voice,"
on stream or some shit 'cause I...
If you give me the line and you give me
like my time to go and
read it and make sure
it sounds American it's totally fine,
but on the spot I'm just like,
"Oh, hey guys, it's Markiplier here."
Like that.
So, I'm like what the fuck?
- Yeah, 'cause you just have
that like familiar like
sound and voice, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like,
I'm the same when I try
to do an American accent.
I just turn into like, a
fuckin' SoCal surfer dude.
- Yeah.
- So, when you have a
British accent, right?
You're tongue is kind of like curled up.
- Yes, I know, I know.
- Yeah, everyone knows.
So, if you wanna do it.
So, then if you wanna be American,
same with Australia, you
just flatten your tongue
and push it back.
- Flatten the tongue, yeah.
- But when I do that, naturally
I sound like Markiplier.
Or like some budget rip off.
- I think it's like the
same subwoofer (indistinct).
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh.
- You're in the same like, sub range.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you wanna make more
voice acting content?
Is that what you feel
like your passion is?
- Yeah, I would love more roles,
but sometimes you have
weeks where you audition
and you get nothing.
- Right.
- But auditioning
is the hardest part.
- It's like soul crushing.
- How many auditions do you
like, record in a week then?
How hard do you look?
- Not as often
as you think 'cause I'm
not with like, an agency.
- Right.
- I freelance for an agency
and sometimes I get auditions for like,
the things you may win or-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right?
But I don't, I just don't get a lot.
When I do get a role, it's like Christmas.
It's like oh my God, I'm gonna
be happy for the next year.
- Right.
- But it's so rare.
I wish I could get more,
- Yeah.
- but I know it's competitive.
- A lot of people
want to do it.
It's really hard even
getting the auditions.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Auditions take a long time,
and for the, as well, I mean obviously,
I'm sure you're the same.
For me, I don't give a shit about like,
the money part of it.
- Of course, voice actors usually do this
because they want to do it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause anime dubs
don't pay well.
- They-
- It's the bragging rights
to say, "I'm in that show."
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Anime pays I think the least
of any type of voice acting.
- No one does anime
voice acting for money.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean,
that's just been true since the beginning
of like the anime industry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's been known that if you wanna get
into the voice acting field
for anime, it's a hobby job.
It's like a passion job.
'Cause you're not gonna be able
to sustain yourself.
- Yeah, I think big bucks
are in like commercials and-
- Yeah, yeah, I think-
- Original animation,
that's the dream.
- Yeah, that'd be cool.
- That'd be cool, right?
- That'd be-
- imagine them animeing stuff
to your voice instead of you trying
to fit your lip flaps
and then reading like,
"Oh, this top is better."
(all laughing)
- Do you know "The Legends
of the Galactic Heroes?"
Do you know that anime?
- Yes, I know that anime.
- I know of it.
- Yeah.
So, I did a voice for one
of the episodes recently.
- [Lily] Oh! Uh huh.
- And oh my God, the lip flaps
in the show were intense.
- Yeah.
- I did another show before that
and the guy most of the time
was just talking to himself in his head,
and I was like, this is fuckin' easy.
- Yeah.
- This is fuckin' great.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so, I didn't have to match anything,
but "Legends of Galactic Heroes"
is like famous for being a very like,
political talking anime.
- Oh.
- I didn't even have
that many lines but I
was struggling so hard.
- To fit.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they were like
so precise lip flaps,
and I was like, why would they do this
'cause in Japanese they don't
even fucking match them.
- Yeah, I think that's
the ironic thing, right?
- Yeah.
- The dubbing process, they
care more about the lip flaps
than the Japanese version.
- Yeah.
- Japanese they're like, "Oh, fuckin'..."
- It's like you have three
seconds to say the lines.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's so bizarre how Japanese
like, don't even give a fuck
about trying to match them.
- Yeah.
- It's like, what?
In English it's such a big deal.
- Yeah, it is.
- Yeah.
- If you look closely,
there's like a bunch
of scenes where like,
the voice acting starts
before or after the movement.
- Oh, yeah, yes, it's really-
- And no one cares.
- That's interesting, wow.
- Yeah.
- But that's not your star role, though.
'Cause you voiced a monkey as well, right?
- I did, yeah, did we
share the Corpse thing?
Did he give you that role as well?
- What-
- Corpse just like messaged
me one day and he was like, "Hey-"
- Oh, is that the anime
where it's like (indistinct)-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, it's like-
- TFTI Corpse.
- It's like the "Danganronpa,"
from the same makers of "Danganronpa."
- I did, I saw all of my friends' part.
I didn't know you were the monkey.
- So yeah, was like in the-
- You're a monkey.
- Yeah, I was a monkey in the-
(all laughing)
- That's his star sign,
that's his star sign.
- Shut up, okay?
Why are you looking at me like
that when you're saying it?
So, yeah, Corpse was like,
"You wanna be a monkey?"
And I was like-
- That's sick.
- That's, fuck yeah.
So, I went on call and they were like,
"Do you have much voice
acting experience?"
And I was like, "Yeah,"
and they were like,
"Well, don't worry about it
'cause it doesn't matter anyway.
You're gonna be a monkey."
(all laughing)
- Could you demonstrate
like, what you did?
- Yeah, so they were like,
"Could you give me a
running monkey sound?"
And they were like
(imitates monkey hooting),
and I was like, "What the fuck?"
How do you not laugh?
That was the problem.
They were like, "Could you do
another one without laughing?"
They would be like, "We want five seconds
of uninterrupted monkey running."
- Monkey running.
- Yeah.
(Connor imitates monkey hooting)
(all laughing)
- But you nailed it,
you nailed it perfectly.
- But yeah.
- You did a great monkey.
- [Joey] One take wonder, baby.
- What can I say?
- Like fucking,
born for this role.
- Yeah, yep, yep.
- Like his career-
- That was it.
- His career peaked there.
- Yeah.
- All this training.
- Monkey voice actor.
(Garnt laughs) Let me know
if you need a monkey, guys.
- Do you watch it afterwards
and you're like, "That's me!
I was-"
- I did.
Yeah, I'm finally a monkey in a show.
- Oh my God, that's cool.
- That's always been
like a dream.
- Are you the kind of
person who is completely
okay hearing your own
voice when you voice act?
- I think when it's in
like an anime or something,
I'm very proud.
I'm like, "Oh, look at,
that's me, that's me."
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, okay.
I voiced in "Miss Nagatoro,"
and that was like the biggest
anime voice then, right?
I was so excited to show Michael.
I'm like, no, it's really cute
and wholesome, I swear honey.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then I showed
him like an episode-
- The first episode?
- It was...
- She goes hard that first episode.
- And he's like, "What am I watching?
Is this a dominatrix movie?"
- In like the first episode she makes
like the main character cry.
- And I'm like, no, but
my character's Yoshi.
She's really cute.
All my scenes were like, cute.
- Oh, okay.
- So, I-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There were so many scenes
where it was just like,
she's just bullying the
shit outta this guy.
- Yeah.
- And they're so mean
and they're like...
It's really weird.
- Yeah, like the first
two episodes especially,
like she does not hold back at all.
- No, no.
- Yeah.
- And there is a worrying amount of people
who are really into it.
- [Garnt] Yeah (laughs).
- I thought it was like a Slice of Life,
like comfy, wholesome from the vibe I got,
and then I watched it, I'm like, oh.
I mean, it does get wholesome.
- Yeah, it does get wholesome.
- Yeah.
- But how to show-
- It's that initial hump of just like,
it's pure like, here's like a
dommy mommy step on me energy.
- Yeah.
- And then it gets wholesome afterwards,
which is just-
- Yeah.
- I didn't know there could be a show
that teeters on Slice of Life
and psychological horror.
(all laughing)
Because for some people,
personally that is an
absolute fuckin' nightmare.
- Right.
- I haven't seen it.
- In real life that wouldn't-
- That would not fly.
- She wouldn't be scary like that-
- Yeah, no.
- It's just a wholesome story
about these four girls-
- I only saw like the porn of it, though.
Like, people were just always posting-
- Oh.
- Oh, that's because
the original creator is a-
- So you (indistinct).
- Right.
- Yes, yeah I heard that he was a hentai.
(all chattering)
- Yeah, Twitter had a field day.
Twitter had fine art.
- Everyone's profile pictures
were the main-
- That girl.
- Yeah, yeah.
That's how I know.
- So, you only watch porn of it, huh?
- No, no, no, I didn't seek it out.
It was on Twitter.
I mean, I follow Joey,
- Okay.
- so, you know.
- So it was just on your feed
and you watched it.
- It was just on my feed.
Yeah, I would not watch it.
- I mean, that's just like
all our feeds at this point,
- Okay.
- especially if you
follow Joey as well, but-
- Sometimes some people
on my followers list,
they re-tweet literally hentai.
- That's probably, yeah.
- Okay, I don't re-tweet
any of it, I just like it.
- I'm not being,
I'm not trying-
- Okay, so-
- [Joey] And it just appears
on other people's list.
- The problem is, okay,
there's some artists
that I really, really like
but they also support other artists,
and it's gone so extreme now
that I've completely forgotten
how weird it is to be scrolling in public
on your Twitter timeline,
and a fuckin' hentai appears.
- Yeah, I'm so scared of browsing,
but oh, big, big melons
just like right there,
and I'm like, oh, fuck!
- I'll tell you what,
because like living in Japan,
everyone just like, keeps to themselves.
So it's totally normal.
- Yeah, no one says anything.
- Like, when I went back
to England on like a tube,
and like there was just like,
on the metro and like, you
see a lotta people around you,
you feel so fucking awkward
and it reminded me of
England how awkward this is,
how not normal this should be.
- Yeah.
- But because living in Japan,
to me it's just become normal now
just to have like full on
anime titties on my timeline.
- Maybe you should just normalize it.
Be proud of who you are.
- I mean, I...
I mean, one day, one day
we'll normalize anime titties.
One day.
- I'm going to Japan next month.
I'm very excited about that.
- Oh yeah, hell yeah.
- Are you able to get in?
- On what visa?
- Yes, yes, OTV trip.
- Oh, awesome.
- Oh, nice.
- So it's a business trip, awesome.
- Yeah, it's a business trip.
- Hell yeah.
- Oo.
- We're gonna hang out in Japan, man.
- Oh because (speaking faintly).
(all laughing)
- When are you guys going?
- We are going...
When does this come out?
(Connor blows raspberry)
- I'm not sure, actually.
- I'm not sure.
- Probably by the time AX comes out.
- Early July probably.
- Yeah, yeah.
Early in July I reckon.
- Sometime in July.
- Okay.
- I'll be there.
- Cool.
- Are you guys going to AX?
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah, yeah.
- Oh, are you?
- I mean, of course we are.
- You're anime-
- We're anime
content creators, right?
- Are you going to AX?
- We're an anime podcast, right?
- Oo.
- What are you gonna do at...
I feel like every year at
AX it gets more crowded.
I can't get in anywhere.
There's just lines
everywhere, people everywhere.
- Yeah.
- We're doing the 21 plus lounge.
- Yeah, we got the 21 plus
lounge this year.
- Oh.
What is that?
How do you get in?
It sounds fun.
- Oh, you can't
because the tickets are all sold out.
- We'll get you in.
- [All] We'll get you in.
- We'll get you in, don't worry.
- Yeah.
- But like, what do you do there?
Like, what do you-
- Drink.
- Oh.
- It's just a party.
It's just an after party.
- Drink and we have like,
a bunch of musical acts
on stage and stuff.
- Oh, that sounds cute.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- Should be good.
- Yeah, like how's the AX
experience for you because you like-
- It's just crowded and hot.
- Because like, you've gone to AX
for like so many years now, right?
- Yeah.
- And it's like,
I remember, I feel like
when AX was manageable,
when was the last time AX was manageable?
- I don't even remember.
- 50 years ago.
- Yeah.
- It's always been crowded and hot
and only go to meet people because that's
where all the weeb friends gather
and like-
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's when you can
say hi to everyone.
- That's what we do.
- [All] Yeah.
- Exactly, but like, I don't know,
aside from that it's just
a glorified meetup for me pretty much.
- It's the same for us as well.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- You can't go to any panels,
I can't like, get into anything.
The lines are long everywhere.
You do see some really cool cosplays.
- Yeah.
- And I do enjoy seeing
the effort people put into AX cosplays.
- Yeah.
- Are you guys cosplaying?
- [All] No.
- You guys should be
like, "Powerpuff Girls."
(all laughing)
- Which ones would we be?
- Oo, okay.
Bubbles.
- What?
(Garnt laughs)
- Blossom, Buttercup.
- I wanna be Buttercup, though.
- You're not a Buttercup.
- What?
- Oh!
- So I'm a Cancer and I'm a Bubbles.
- No, no, no, no.
You just-
- Maybe if you watched "Arcane."
- You can-
- Maybe if I watched "Arcane"
I'll finally be a Libra Buttercup.
- I don't know you guys too well,
but from my expression you give off
like the most like comfy,
like wholesome vibes.
- I'll take that.
- You give off like,
the most like strict, like teacher vibes,
and you're like a balance.
(Connor laughs)
- Why strict teacher?
- I don't know, you just
give off like a very like,
not a, how do you pronounce it?
- [Guys] Authoritative.
- Not too much of that but just like,
a very like, you're very responsible,
like that kinda vibe.
- Oh, wow. Thank you.
- Is he?
- Wow.
- That's the vibe I'm getting,
just from talking to you guys.
- Wow, oh damn.
- I think you've been blinded
by something, I don't know.
- I'm responsible.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's okay, it's not
bad being Hufflepuff.
You're like the comfy, the friendly.
- No, I'm okay with being a Hufflepuff.
I'm not okay with being Bubbles.
- Last time I saw you
you called me a child.
(Joey laughs)
- I don't remember that.
- In what context?
- What context was this?
- Do you remember the Anime Awards?
- The Crunchyroll?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You were there at the last one.
- I called you a child?
Why did I call you a child?
You must've done something childlike.
- No, no, no, I think it was-
- He was probably a child.
- You're correct by the way.
He is a child.
- I can't remember
what happened but you were like,
"Connor, I'm not young, I'm old,"
or something you said to me,
and you were like,
"You're a child, Connor."
And I was like,
- I see.
- I couldn't remember why this happened.
- But I think
it was because I stole the,
you know we got the awards, right?
And then we opened them and had that case.
- Yes.
- I like ran and like, took them.
And then I-
- What?
- Yeah, so I took it home.
- Oh.
- The thing-
- Were you allowed to?
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
Yeah, so you know like when the pull out
the winner and it's like the
kinda sake barrel-esque thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, oh my God,
I remember that.
- Oh, you mean
the "Demon Slayer" one?
You mean the last one?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I just took one.
Like, it's cool.
(all laughing)
- Crunchyroll people are
like, "That's where it is!"
- Well, they haven't had a show since.
Maybe I'm the reason.
I broke their like, financial constraints.
Like, me stealing this one thing
just bankrupted them.
- Crunchyroll.
Wow, that was like three years ago?
- Yeah, that was a really
- I think it was more
- like strange vibe.
- than three years ago.
- That was strange.
That was a strange-
- Yeah, 'cause I didn't go
to that Crunchyroll Awards.
- You was there before.
- Yeah,
I went to the one before that.
- You were at the one
before I think as well.
- Or both of them.
- Yes, I was at both of those.
- Yeah, the one where we like,
went on stage or something like that.
That was-
- Oh my God, yes.
- Yeah.
- 2018?
- We presented an award together.
I can't remember
- Yes!
- what award it was.
- "Slice of Life?"
Was it?
- Oh yeah,
I think I presented comedy.
- Right.
- It might've been one of those, yeah.
- Oh my God, that was...
Oh my God, yeah, I know what
you mean about that one.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Listen, the years
start blending together
and I forget like, I've
known some of you for like...
I've known of you guys
for a very long time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, it's 'cause we
like, never really interact.
- Yes.
- We kinda like do
our own kinda, yeah.
- The first real time
was the kinda Crunchyroll
and the hentai thing.
That was nice.
And then yeah like,
the award and the podcast.
- The awards and your podcast.
Yeah-
- I don't think we-
- I think it's the first time
for all of us.
- We've never really.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
I think it's just like, I
think with how creators are,
we're all aware of each other,
but because we're
completely different circles
we're like halfway
across the world or like,
yeah, we're halfway
across the world.
- Yeah, and we all
know each other.
We're mutuals on Twitter.
That's basically like a acquaintance.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
- It's like a giant school where
I'm choosing to sit at
your guys's table today,
but I'm gonna go back to my table.
- Right, okay.
- The one time I will
grace you with my presence.
- No, no, it's not like that.
- So, are you excited
for your trip to Japan?
I am super excited.
Last time I went, like it was,
I just remember it being,
well, we went in November,
so the weather was like
so amazing.
- That's a good time,
that's a really good time.
- Yeah, really good time.
- That's like, one of the best times.
You're going in July
this time unfortunately,
which is like-
- Oo!
- I am scared of that, the heat.
- Have fun with that, dude.
- People underestimate it so much.
They're like, how bad can it be?
- No, it's bad.
- Yeah.
- It's horrible.
- I've been to Korea during the summer,
and it's just-
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I know what it's like.
- Yeah, you do.
- I love how there's like,
so many like, especially Southeast Asians,
they're like, "No, we know what hot is."
And then they go to Japan, they're like,
"I'm sorry, I don't know what hot is."
- Wait, is Japan somewhere like-
- It's worse than Southeast Asia.
- Oh.
- It makes Southeast Asians-
- Because the thing for me is a lot
of Southeast Asia infrastructure
is built around the fact that it's going
to be very, very hot and humid.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Japan less so,
but also I think the humidity in Japan
is also worse than some of
the times Southeast Asia.
- Oh.
- Your hair
is fucked immediately.
- Yeah.
- Really? Wow.
- It's like 90% humidity.
- Okay I will
- Cry, just cry.
- Comfort myself with the food at least.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I love the food there.
- The cabs have AC.
- Huh?
- All the cabs have AC.
- That's great.
- All the trains have AC.
- All the trains...
Eh, depends.
When it's super, super rammed
the AC doesn't do anything.
- Oh, yeah, of course, but.
- I heard that, one thing I liked
about Japan was that it felt walkable.
- [Guys] Yeah.
- Whereas-
- Especially compared to here.
- No, I feel like I'm committing a crime
when I cross the road here.
I feel like you're not
supposed to do that.
- Yeah, a lot of the cities
here are built around cars.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
- There's not enough
public transportation.
- Yeah, like I just wanna pop outside,
go get some quick food and here it's like-
- You can't do that.
- No.
- It's an effort.
- Yes.
- You have to like,
make like a mental commitment to go out
and like waste like 15,
20 minutes at least,
that's at least.
But in Japan you can just pop out-
- You walk out to the convenience store.
- Exactly, it's so good.
- Exactly, yeah.
- It's so good.
- And the convenient store is amazing.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- I could live off of
the convenience stores.
- How many times have
you been to Japan now?
- Twice.
- Twice?
- Once was with Pocky.
Like, it was like five years ago.
It was for a sponsor.
- Right.
- But it was really fun.
Second time was with friends,
like November like three years ago.
- Did you ever leave Tokyo?
- Yeah, we went to like, sorry,
I don't know what it's called anymore.
- Osaka? Kyoto?
- Nevermind, we didn't
leave Tokyo I guess.
(all laughing)
- Maybe.
- Maybe you went
to different parts of Tokyo.
- Maybe yeah, that's what I mean.
- Did you take a train that
was longer than an hour?
- No.
- Okay, okay.
- You definitely didn't leave Tokyo.
- What's that place that starts with an A?
The...
- Asakusa?
- No.
- Akihabara?
- Yeah.
- Oh!
(all laughing)
- Yeah, that's still
definitely within Tokyo.
- I feel so silly.
- That's definitely Tokyo.
- That's like as central as it gets.
- Harajuku?
- Oh, yeah.
- Harajuku, yeah.
- Shi...
- Shinjuku?
- Shinjuku.
Oh my God, the shopping was so good.
- Yeah.
- Shibuya?
- Shibuya! That's...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was so nice.
(guys laughing)
It was just so like, nice.
- Yeah.
- Everything tasted great.
Everything was pretty, like anime,
maid girls on the corner
selling you to the cafe.
(Joey laughs)
Every type of maid cafe.
- Dude, I hate those.
- It's interesting.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was like a cultural shift I guess.
Like, I would never see that in America.
- Did you go into a maid cafe?
- I did.
Oh, my friends did but I did not.
- Right.
- But they all got like
pictures with maids.
Michael got a picture with a maid
and she wrote her name like,
Michael with three Ls.
(all laughing)
- Michael-la-la-la.
- Like, she had like cat
ears and he was like,
looking happy and I was like,
- Right.
- this is so...
(all laughing)
And then they give you like,
the little plates of omurice or whatever.
They like, create hearts on it and stuff.
- Yeah, they write something on them.
- I'm like, man, I thought this shit
was in the anime but it's like real.
- Yeah, I forget now because we've
been living in Japan for so long that-
- It's like normal, yeah.
- It's so interesting.
- It's just normal now, right?
- I mean, Akihabara
kinda got I don't know,
wounded by the coronavirus.
Like, a lotta stuff shut down.
- Yeah.
- That is so sad.
- SEGA sold off all the arcades.
So now that's gone.
(Lily gasps)
- Yeah, that's so sad.
- It's not called SEGA anymore.
- It's not SEGA, it's called GIGO.
- GIGO, that's it.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- But it's in the same
font as the SEGA one.
- Yeah, it's really-
- It's just the same thing.
- It's like in an anime,
you know how they have WokDonalds?
- Yeah.
- Like, imagine it happening in real life.
It's like-
- Okay.
- It's like
- Oh my God.
- an alternate reality you step into.
- But the arcades are really cool,
but they're slowly just getting rid
of all the games and
putting in claw machines.
- Oh no.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think arcade culture is
like, slowing dying in Japan.
- That's so sad 'cause I still
love like, you know ROUND1?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I love ROUND1,
I love arcade games.
- That one's so good here.
- It's actually pretty good here.
I like it a lot.
- There's a ROUND1 here?
- They're really good.
- There's three here I think.
- Oh!
- I think ROUND1
is an American company, is it not?
- I thought it was Japanese.
- I'm not sure.
- Yeah.
- It was one or the other.
- I actually don't know.
- The one in Kabukara is really good.
- Oh, the one in Kabukara is-
- That's one's-
- The one on Sunshine Road.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They have a Daiso in
LA as well, don't they?
- Lots of Daiso's.
- That was so random to see.
- Really?
- I didn't know Daiso
was here in LA.
- Daiso's very common.
- But it wasn't a dollar, right?
- Huh?
- It wasn't a dollar?
- I don't know, I didn't go in.
- I think $1.75, $2,
it's all interchangeable.
- It's so weird, it's like going to Japan
and seeing a Dollar Store there.
I'm just like what?
- Dollar Tree.
- Dollar Tree?
- Yeah, like a Dollar Tree there.
It's so random to see.
- I think Daiso's
better though.
- Yeah, because like in
Australia we have Daiso as well,
but everything's $2.50.
- Oh.
- Right.
- So I'm like, it's not quite the same.
You can't call it a Dollar Store.
- A dollar and change.
- It's still...
Yeah, they still have
really cheap nice stuff.
I really like Daiso.
It's nice.
- Daiso I've repped more
than Dollar Tree, I will say.
- Oh yeah.
- Daiso is a place
you go to discover like,
gadgets that you didn't know
you needed until you see it.
- Yeah, right, yeah.
- And then you're like, that's genius.
And then you kinda just
never really use it.
- They're probably like,
"It's a mop for your face,
and it looks like a normal mop."
- No, I bought that thing where like,
you can put like a boiled egg inside of it
and then it shuts and
it perfectly cuts into
like these perfect shapes
for you salad.
- That would never work.
- Used it once and I was like, "Let's go!"
And then I never used it again.
It's just been in the back of my cabinet
the entire time.
- Yeah.
- I bought like, the glove
that's like a washing up glove.
So you can put like
washing up liquid on it
and you just like,
basically just man handle-
- I also bought the slippers
that look like a mop.
- Those are something I bought as well
and then I never used them.
- I never used them.
- 'Cause they were useless
in the end.
They were useless.
- They were just spreading out the shit.
They weren't actually like
collecting anything at all.
- Yeah, 'cause if you're walking
on the clean places with the mop,
it's gonna defeat
- Yeah.
- that whole purpose.
- Yeah, it doesn't work
the exact same way.
- No, it doesn't work
like a mop.
- No, no.
- It's not like
you have a Roomba where you're like-
- Very specific things.
- Yeah, it's things though that
you look at and you're like,
I don't need that,
- That's cute.
- but then you buy it and you're like,
all right, I'll use it once.
- Yeah, 'cause it's like
all the gadgets you see
on like the infomercials or something,
but like all in just like one place.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's the best way
I can describe Daiso.
It's one big infomercial
fuckin' gadget place.
- Yeah, true, true.
- But of course, everything
is cheap as well.
- Yeah, whenever I need
something really quickly,
like Tupperware of fuckin' whatever,
paper clips, whatever it is,
it's just like yeah, I
know Daiso will have it.
- Do they sell GamerSupps water bottles?
- They do not, they do not.
- No, but we do have
a link in the description, though.
I mean-
- With, yeah,
what's your code?
- "Trash Taste".
- "Trash Taste", I'd say.
- That's our code right, Meilyne?
- For what, 5% off, 10% off?
What is it?
- I don't know.
- A specific percent off.
- Okay.
- Why you callin' me out, dude?
- [Lily] I don't know, I was just curious.
- I'll come on your show and-
- Check out the description below.
(all laughing)
So, it's like sponsors wanting like the-
- Oh my God, thank you for
doing our admins for us.
- Oh, yeah, no.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is the most amount of exposure.
This is awesome.
- I actually think
the water tastes better.
Like, I feel more-
(all laughing)
I feel more rejuvenated.
- Oh my God.
- So, you talked about Japanese
food being really good,
but I think like the LA food culture
is also like really good, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- One of the best parts about living in LA
is like you want like, Indian food,
you can get really good Indian food.
You want Japanese food, you
want like, Chinese food,
like it's so diverse.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Someone who specializes
in like each cuisine.
- Where's the British food, though?
- What, beans on toast?
- Yeah (laughs).
Where's fish and chips?
- The fish and chips.
- I want you to bring up
British food with Michael.
- Really?
- He will shit on it so hard.
I'm so sorry.
- No, no, no.
- He just hates British food.
- I'll go to him and I'll be like,
really serious about it and I'll be like,
"Listen,
- Oh, please.
- it's my favorite food."
- But have you had
a Tesco meal deal?
- Has he had
Then you haven't had proper British food.
- I would pay for you to
mention British food to Michael.
- I'll do that.
- Yeah, you gotta do that.
- You know how many times
he's made fun of your jellied eels?
- That's not a thing.
- Yeah but,
that's low hanging fruit.
- Yeah.
- That is low hanging.
He says that you guys like,
colonized India with
spices but the best thing
you could think of was beans on toast.
Like, he just shits on it constantly.
I'm like, "Have you ever been to Britain?"
He's like, "No."
- Have you?
- No.
- Why not?
(Garnt laughs)
- I've been to...
The only place I've been
to in Europe is Germany.
That's it.
I stopped listening.
- For like Games Con?
- [Lily] Huh?
- For like, Games Con or something?
- No, no, no, it's just
like some sponsored thing.
I don't really remember.
I did like that still water,
I had to pay for it and like,
I kept asking sparkling.
Sparkling water just tastes
like spicy water to me.
I don't like it.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah.
- You have to specify
like tap water.
- Tap water.
- Yeah.
- No, I kept paying like three euros
for still water or something.
- Oh my God.
- Jesus.
- (laughs) I think the
last day I just stayed
in my hotel and ordered room service.
- Oh no.
UK's fun.
- I do wanna visit UK.
I think it's like one of the places
I wanna visit eventually.
You think I could get away the accent?
- Like-
- Oo.
- [Lily] Oh, please, can we try?
- [Guys] Uh...
- I mean, we could
- It depends how good
- try if you want.
- your accent is.
It depends how good your accent is.
- Have it a try,
- [Connor and Garnt] give it a shot.
- Okay.
Keep talking about something, though.
- All right, so yeah,
you like beans on toast?
- Yeah?
- Oh, I love beans on toast.
(all laughing)
- You sound like you got
rejected for a "Crown" audition.
- It's that, "Oh, oh.
Let me see."
- "I'm reading for the
part of Queen Elizabeth."
- "Oh yes, I love beans on toast."
- Do people actually eat beans on toast?
- Yes.
- Yeah,
people do eat beans on toast.
- Literally like, growing up obviously
'cause it's really easy to make.
You just-
- Dude,
the fuckin' breakfast food
at the hotel
- Yeah, literally.
- is just nothing but beans on toast.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wow.
- Sausages and beans on toast.
That's it.
- My mum used
to make beans on toast
- I mean, that sounds
- all the time.
- pretty good.
I do like beans and sausages.
- I mean, like,
do you have beans on toast by itself or?
- So, yeah, sometimes you would have that,
but normally it always
came with cheese on top.
So, my mom would always make it,
maybe like once a week.
It would always be like,
beans, toast, cheese,
and then a fried egg on top,
and then you put-
- That sounds pretty good.
- That sounds good.
- Yeah, and that's fucking good.
I love that.
- 'Cause normally
you have beans on toast with
like a full English breakfast.
- Yeah, you have it
with other stuff.
- You have the full English,
and then you have-
- Yes, like the tomatoes
and the hash browns.
- Tomatoes?
- And liverwurst.
- (laughs) Liverwurst?
- Do you like black pudding?
- Black pudding, what is that?
- It's coagulated blood, I think, right?
- It's a blood sold with,
yeah, yeah.
- Or congealed, right?
- Congealed?
- Congealed.
- Congealed blood.
- No, that's not pudding
in my head. It's just not.
- Well, yeah,
it doesn't taste like dessert, yeah.
- Well, it's also called
blood sausage, right?
- Blood sausage, yeah.
- Blood sausage.
- That's right.
- Huh, interesting.
My parents bought me
McDonald's breakfasts.
Like, real American.
- Honestly,
I fuck with McDonald's breakfast.
- I love McDonald's breakfast.
- It's so fuckin' good.
- Their pancakes are perfect.
- Oh.
- I don't rate the pancake.
- Oh, yeah, okay, okay, I don't rate them.
- I thought were getting
the Sausage McMuffins.
- Yeah, the Sausage McMuffins
with the hash brown.
- Right, right?
I thought we were like
bonding over something and you
had to mention pancakes?
- No, no!
Their pancakes are perfectly circular.
It's perfect.
- No, I am like against eating pancakes
for breakfast.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I don't think it's a breakfast food.
- It's not, it's cake.
- Yeah.
- It is, it's cake.
- It's like Americans
have tricked each other
into eating dessert for breakfast.
- Do you like McGriddles?
- Yeah, I like McGriddles.
- Oh, McGriddles are so good.
It's like a pancake bun.
There's a Chicken McGriddle.
Oh my fucking God.
- I just feel like
you have a pancake obsession.
- I love pancakes.
- Do you like IHOP?
- Eh.
- Yeah, IHOP's ruined pancakes for me.
- They are kind of mid honestly.
- Well, what would you say is a place
that has good pancakes then?
- The pancake specialty restaurants,
you could probably Yelp and look it up.
Like Oscar's Pancake Bar
or something like that.
(all laughing)
That would be good.
- So, you have it for breakfast
or just like any time?
- I'm an adult, I can
eat it anytime I want.
But I think like, I
really like the standard
like bowl of rice, some soup,
maybe some like grilled
fish or meat, egg, kimchi.
I don't know, that's like
a good breakfast to me.
- Yeah.
I thought you had that with pancake.
I was like, that's a...
- That's a lotta carbs.
- Pancake, yeah, it is very carb heavy.
Like, pancakes, waffles, like, cereal.
It's all sugar and so not good for you.
I can't believe we
normalized that growing up.
Like, I can't believe that was normal.
- What? Pancakes?
- Like pancakes for breakfast.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's weird.
- It is weird.
- [Garnt and Joey]
That's what we're saying.
- That's what we're trying to say.
- Yeah.
- I like bread, bread for
breakfast is pretty good.
It's very European.
- Yeah but like,
- Just bread?
- pancakes are a little bit different.
- Pancakes are sweet.
- Yeah.
- The syrup and everything.
- Like savory bread is great.
Like, just some toast,
or just a baguette,
- Toast is good.
- just rip it apart
- I like toast.
- and eat some of it.
- Toast.
- I love that.
- I just don't
even eat breakfast.
- Oh God, I'm so hungry now.
I'm going to dinner
with Michael after.
- Shouldn't have said that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Holy crap I'm hungry.
- Yeah, lucky I'm not a breakfast person.
Like, breakfast is the meal
I probably eat the least
because I don't know,
I feel like a full English or
something is fucking great,
and American breakfast is great as well
but it's just like, so heavy.
Especially like Japanese breakfast.
When you go to like a Ryokan
and you have like a
proper Japanese breakfast,
it's like-
- Yeah,
I love Japanese breakfast.
- It's like a three course meal
for breakfast.
- The kaiseki breakfast.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's too much,
it's too much.
- It's way too much.
- It is too much, yeah.
But also English breakfasts are too much.
I remember like day three of MCN
and I was having the hotel breakfast
and it was like a full plate
of like make your own English breakfast.
Dude, by like 12 p.m. I'm so sick
because it's so oily.
- [Connor and Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Garnt] It's really bad.
- And it's a lot of oil in the morning.
I'm just like, ugh.
- It's a lot of, yeah.
- It's like when you've
had a long day of drinking
and the next day you're like-
- I get, amazing hangover food.
- Oh, that sounds good.
- Yeah, it is.
- I bet, but-
- It's like, that's why it's
a British breakfast, right?
- Yeah.
- Perfect hangover food,
but like you eat it everyday
and it's just way too heavy.
- It's so ugh, yeah.
- I mean, I do like miso
soup in the morning, though.
That is like the best.
- That's nice.
- Me too, you can't go wrong with that.
- Japanese miso (sighs).
- I'm so hungry.
- Okay.
- That's it, though.
I only need miso soup.
I don't need anything else.
Just one miso soup just like-
- And also maybe like
a small bowl of rice.
- Do you know tonjiru?
Do you know that?
It's like miso soup with like
pork and like veg and stuff.
- No, but that sounds delicious.
- Like a pork broth.
It's like pork broth.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What's your favorite food
to eat when you go to Japan?
- Sushi.
- Sushi?
Okay, okay, okay.
- Oh.
- I remember too,
like when I went with
Pocky the first time,
we were on like this
underground subway, whatever,
we were hungry and I'm like,
"Oh, there's a sushi place,
let's just go there."
- Yeah.
- We go there, eat,
it's omakase and I'm
like, this is so good.
Like, it's just like a
random hole in the wall place
that we sat down and it was so good.
- Right, yeah.
No, like sushi is fuckin'
incredible in Japan
because of course it is, right?
But like, I like even think
the cheap conveyor belt sushis-
- Oh, dude, the one
dollar sushi's so good.
- I love those.
- Those are my favorite
actually because I love like,
the omakase set and everything like that,
but like sometimes you just wanna
fuckin' stuff yourself
with like good sushi
and you're like, even though
you're just paying like $1
for like the conveyor belt sushi,
it's better than like-
- It still slaps, dude.
- It's better than most places
you can find abroad, honestly.
- Yep.
- Yeah, Sushiro.
Sushiro is so nice.
- Definitely,
because I remember you
guys were tellin' me
about like, the horror
stories of British sushi.
- Oh my God.
- I'm sorry, what?
- No, no, no, no.
It's not British style sushi,
it's sushi made in-
- No, no, no.
It's sushi made in the UK.
- I imagine like,
like rice with like, beans.
(all laughing)
- A single bean.
- You're hilarious, not.
- Beans on rice.
It's the same thing.
- Sorry, sorry-
- Her Royal Majesty's Spam.
Oh no, that's fuckin' right.
- That's literally your life.
- Black pudding sushi.
- Yeah.
- No, what was it? YO! Sushi?
Is that the-
- Oh, that's fuckin'-
- That was the worst one.
- It's an abomination.
- So, for someone who like's, British,
and like sushi shouldn't like-
- No, no, no, no.
- It shouldn't.
- But sometimes in America,
there's good sushi here too,
but sometimes I just really want like,
a deep fried California
roll topped with like,
big salmon and like drizzled
with like three different kind of sauces.
- I feel like that's
not even sushi, though.
Like, I feel like they're
both different types of sushi.
- Yeah.
- But I like that.
- Fusion.
- Yeah.
- I like those.
- Yeah, sometimes it's
just really good.
- I personally don't count that as sushi,
but like I won't say no
to a California roll.
- Yeah.
- Like, it just slaps.
- Because you can't
get it in Japan at all.
- [Joey] You can't get it in Japan, no.
- They don't-
- There's no California rolls
in Japan?
- No, no.
- I think you'd be like, killed
if you were a sushi chef.
- What do you mean they
won't put avocado in my roll?
- Fuck no! Fuck no!
(Garnt laughing)
But these dudes train like
15 years to slap rice around.
Like, they're not gonna
put like avocado on.
- No, but it's delicious.
The cream cheese?
- Yeah, okay.
Yeah, but like again, I
don't count that as sushi.
- I know, I know.
- It's a good meal, but like,
actually I think I have seen-
- It's like an American
take on sushi, right?
- No, I have seen one place
that sells California rolls.
- No, because like 99%
of sushi places you go
to don't even do rolls.
- No.
- It's like,
rolls just like don't
really exist in Japan.
- They just like cut like mocki, I guess.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the closest
you're gonna get.
- Oh God, I'm so excited
to eat food there.
I'm so hungry right now.
Sushi is like my favorite
food of all time.
- Oh, that's good.
- Going to Japan is like,
I'm just going to eat
sushi every single day.
Every day.
- And you're never gonna
get bored of it because-
- I actually won't.
- I thought I would but like,
sushi's the one Japanese meal
where I ate sushi before moving to Japan
and I ate it more after moving to Japan
and I just like, have not got bored
of it at all.
- Wow, I'm jealous.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- But like, aside from sushi,
is there anything else you
like about Japanese food?
Like-
- Do you rate ramen?
- Oh.
Okay, I like instant ramen
more than regular ramen.
- Oh (laughing)!
- I like the, you cut the packet that you-
- What the fuck?
- I think it's just, what is it?
- What the fuck
did you just say?
- I think it's the MSG,
or the sodium but it just
tastes better for me.
- Probably the MSG.
- No!
No!
- Right?
- What am I listening to?
- I don't think you've been
to good ramen places in Japan.
- I can admit that you could say
maybe Ramen's too heavy
normally or it's too much,
but saying it's better?
- I like the taste of it better.
- [Connor] I don't think you've
been to a good ramen place.
- Okay, well, in LA,
- I don't think you've been
to a good ramen place.
- I go to a ramen place,
right? And it looks good and I'm like,
"Can I have an extra egg, please?"
And they're like, "Oh, that'll be $3,"
and I'm like, can I have like-
- Why are you speaking in a
British accent? (all laughing)
- "$3."
(all chattering)
- Are they suddenly in LA?
- Are they in pounds?
- [Joey and Connor] "$3."
- No, like, "Can I have like, seaweed?"
And they're like, "Oh yeah, that's $1.50,"
and they gave me like one type-
- Oh, what the fuck?
- Yeah.
- Like, why are the
toppings so expensive, bro?
- Yeah.
- It is heavy.
- [Garnt] But does it taste good?
- I mean, it's good but it's just like,
I think instant ramen,
it fits my palette more.
I don't know, I just really like it.
- I think you need to go to like
a proper good ramen place in Japan.
- Oh, dude, have you tried tsukemen?
That's the best one.
- That was pretty good.
I will admit that's good.
- Tsukemen slaps.
- Yeah.
- But there's nothing like,
it's like 1 a.m., you're sad as shit.
You bring out the pot, you
open the Shin Ramyun Black,
you know Shin Ramyun?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I've had Shin Ramyun.
I fuckin' love Shin Ramyun.
- Yeah, with the egg and
the cheese and it just hits.
- But I mean, like-
- Isn't that like,
Korean flavored?
- Sorry, yeah, I like Korean ramen better.
- I think we found it.
- Yeah, we figured it out.
We figured it out.
- I'm Korean, so.
(Garnt laughs)
- Well, luckily the Japanese ramen stores
are open like 24/7 normally.
- Oh yeah, well, yeah.
- 'Cause you guys like to-
- Most places are open
up till like four a.m.
- Yeah, you go there at two a.m.,
that's a bunch
- I do remember eating
- of drunk people.
- ramen in japan
and I do remember it being very delicious.
So maybe it's just been
like, so long I forgot.
- Is it because it's not
spicy enough in Japan?
Well, Shin Ramyun's like pretty spicy.
- You know what?
Maybe it is the spice.
- So is Korean ramen.
Korean ramen's-
- Yeah,
I like the spice a lot.
- Yeah.
- I did order like, non spicy,
so maybe that's why.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there's a lotta
places that do spicy ramen
if that's how-
- I will try that next time.
Maybe-
- You should go
to the place that Connor
and I went to (laughs).
- What's it called?
- Oh no, no, no, no.
- Okay, nevermind.
- That was like hottest ramen.
- Scottish?
- Hottest.
- "Scottish."
- Scottish ramen.
- It was the accent, the accent sorry.
- You just pour whiskey into it.
- (laughs) This broth of like...
- [Joey] Broth of whiskey.
(Garnt laughing)
- I do like their poached, the egg,
the hard boiled egg-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I like those as well.
- Yeah, it's like brown
and there's a gooey center.
That shit's so fucking good.
- It's really nice
'cause it's like-
- You're talking about, yeah.
- Oh, I am so hungry. Oh my
God, tamagoyaki, that shit's-
- Tamagoyaki? Yeah.
- Tamagoyaki.
- Okonomiyaki.
That one's fucking good.
- Okay, that's good.
- That's just pancakes.
I mean, you love pancakes,
right?
- Yeah, I love pancakes.
- No, you guys don't rate okonomiyaki.
- Okay, I think it's okay.
I didn't think it was bad,
I just think it's okay.
- I will not except
this slander.
- It's the "Kaisen"
of fucking Japanese foods, okay, Joey?
- What do you think
about "Jujutsu Kaisen?"
- Okay, he thinks it's okay.
- It's okay.
- I really like it.
- I really like it as well,
yeah.
- I think it's okay.
- Yes!
- Oh my God.
- Oh, fuckin' hell.
- Yes.
- Well, you also haven't watched "Arcane,"
so I'm sure that...
- Should we take that back then?
- You're associating
with the bad take man.
- Well, these days, I feel anime,
it's really hard for me to find
an anime that I like and
I will keep watching,
'cause like the older I get,
I'm just like I don't have time anymore.
And it has to be really
good for me to stay.
So, right now the only thing
I'm really enjoying kinda
is like "Spy Family."
- "Spy Family?" Yeah.
- I think that's super fun to watch.
- Yeah.
- Well, so is like, everyone.
- Cute premises.
- [Connor and Lily] Yeah.
- I think it's just like,
I don't know how it's gotten
so popular so quickly,
but it's just like a show that
everyone unanimously agrees
is just really, really good.
- It's just cute, charming,
and it reminds me of-
- Yeah, I've not heard
of a single person calling it mid
and that's like a first
with showing an anime.
- Dude, oh my God, this AX
is just gonna be all like,
"Spy Family" cosplay.
- It's just
- This is the year of "Spy Family."
- No, it's gonna be the year of "Genshin."
- I would fight for that.
- 'Cause we-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You wanna fight me? Oh my God.
- We were at MCN which is like
the British like Comic-Con,
and pretty much
- Interesting.
- every third cosplayer was
a "Genshin" character, yeah.
- Yeah, "Genshin" character,
yeah.
- It's crazy how like,
popular "Genshin" is.
Like, that's insane.
- Yes.
- Do you play "Genshin?"
- Well, okay, so I didn't
used to and then I got cast,
I went in this "Genshin" rabbit hole.
I was like, playing the game.
I was spending money.
I was rolling for five start characters.
I was watching "Genshin" MMDs on YouTube.
Like, it was bad.
(Joey laughs)
I'm like, yeah, I like, yeah.
- So, you became a full
on "Genshin Impact" addict basically.
- I was like that sounds
normal up until the MMD part.
(all laughing)
- I'm not proud of it.
I had a day where I'm
just like, looking...
People just...
I think the models are free to use, right?
Like they're-
- Are they?
- Yeah, they share like,
the models and so people
take the character models and make
them dance to like cute
Japanese weeb songs and stuff.
- Right, right.
- And I'm like,
oh, it's kinda cute and
I just kept clicking.
- Nah, we've gone full circle.
We've reverted back to
like, the "Miku" days now.
- Yeah.
- Where you'd have
like all the OG MMDs
of like "Miku" characters.
- I remember "Miku."
Oh, the vocaloid era.
- The vocaloid,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God.
- Dude,
that was so big back then.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
I feel so old.
- Somehow "Genshin's" brought
that like fuckin' phase back now.
I didn't know, yeah.
- Yeah.
- The "Miku" era is back, yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, I remember.
- Yeah.
So, is "Genshin" your first gacha game?
(all laughing)
- Oh.
- You can say it.
- Okay, so I played lots of gacha games
and I stopped because I have a problem.
- Yeah, right.
- I played "Summoner's War" for a bit.
- Oh, that's notorious
- Oh!
- for being a money sinker.
- Yeah.
- Wow, wow.
- I got cast in "Cookie Run."
- Okay.
- So I'm like,
oh, this should be really fun.
Let me try it, and I uninstalled it
and I'm like I need the five star cookies,
and I just keep...
It's terrible.
- What's the most you've
spent on a gacha game?
- Let's just say that I spent more
than what they paid me to voice.
- No!
- I was about to ask,
is like the worst thing
that could happen to you,
you get casted in the gacha game
'cause that means you're like obligated
to play it.
- To play the gacha game.
- And you're gonna get
really, really into it.
- I basically paid back the
money that they paid me.
- It's like a circular economy, right?
- It's terrible.
- That's how it works.
- That's just money laundering.
- I promise, I stopped spending money,
like I stopped playing because I had
to uninstall like, "Cookie
Run" and "Genshin Impact."
- I find the best way to make sure
I never play a gacha game is I mean-
- Just don't install it.
- Well, yeah, that,
but if I promote it they give you
like a cracked account, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And that ruins the game.
- It does.
- 'Cause then you're like,
well, I have everything.
- Yeah.
- And now there's no point in me getting
my credit card out and spending.
I don't wanna play this game.
- They're very good
at like enticing you to like...
Look at all those
"Genshin" character demos.
- They probably have
like, tons of peoples jobs
to just find out what
made you most addicted.
- And it's just very well done to be fair,
like the characters are beautiful.
The sound, music, everything.
Like, I'm on a "Genshin" show, I swear,
but like, it's just really pretty.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like,
the aesthetics are nice.
- Yeah, I mean like, I think there's a lot
of good things about
"Genshin" but I'm also like,
an ex "Genshin" player.
I've also got out.
I've been like, one
year "Genshin" free now.
I'm very happy.
- Like "Genshin" players anonymous.
- [Garnt] Yeah (laughs).
- I'm one year sober from "Genshin."
- I recently re-installed it.
- [Guys] Oh!
- No, 'cause you have like
this rhythm game that came up,
that drum thing and I love rhythm games.
- You need to come to more
of these therapy sessions.
- I played it and I just
never really got into it.
I kinda just played around and I kinda had
a little bit of fun,
but it never really hooked me.
- Yeah, same.
- I do think the world of "Genshin,"
like surpasses what the actual game...
Like, people like cosplaying it,
drawing it, covering music,
- Right.
- all of that, is like way stronger.
- Yeah, the community is insane.
- The community is crazy.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I would enjoy it.
- Like, the community
is crazy and it's like
a really like tight knit
like cool community
from what I've seen as well.
- Oh my God, that is...
- And yeah, but like I think
what got me into "Genshin"
or what sold me on
"Genshin" was actually just,
I don't know, the feeling it gave you.
Like, it's the combination of just like,
the landscape and like the music
was like so fuckin' beautiful.
- Yes.
- And like,
you didn't really get
that in the first area
but when you discovered the leeway,
oh my God, that's when the game
actually got like good for me.
- I agree.
- Or like,
but those are the exact reasons why
I just opted to play "Breath
of the Wild" over "Genshin."
- "Breath of the Wild's" fantastic.
- Because it's like
the exact same feeling,
but in my opinion the game
play's just way more fun.
- It is, but-
- Yeah.
- Cute girls.
- And I think that's
a big reason why I just thought,
and I'm like the cute girls
almost got me.
- Cute girls.
- They almost got me until I saw
the price tag and then I was like,
and I was like-
- I've already completed
"Breath of the Wild" and I don't know
when the fuck "Breath of
the Wild 2" is coming out.
It just fills that
like, nice little niche.
Because "Genshin" is
like infinite content.
Well, it's not really infinite content.
- It's a lot, yeah.
- But it makes
you feel like it for the longest time
and then you realize it becomes
like a part-time job.
That's when you know you're addicted.
- Anything that'll stop
me from playing "League,"
I'll take it.
(Garnt laughs)
- "League" isn't that bad, I swear.
- Do you still play "League" often?
- Not often, so.
- Why do you still wanna play it?
- It's like your ex
girlfriend or boyfriend.
- Okay, okay, as someone who-
- So, you're in
an abusive relationship.
- It's not abusive, we just like,
maybe it's better if we part,
but then like, I miss them.
I'm like, "Hey, what are you doing?
It's one a.m."
- "Hey, my parents aren't home, dude."
(Lily speaking indistinctly)
(all laughing)
- It's like the ex-girlfriend
that never leaves the conversation out.
It's like, "Yeah, this
is cool, but my ex."
- I think moving to Japan
kind of killed it for me.
- [Lily] Wow.
- 'Cause the servers suck.
- Yeah, and also no one
really plays it anymore.
- No one plays it.
- Yeah, no one plays it.
- I thought "League" is popular in Japan.
- No.
- It's I think,
the least popular server,
but the people on the server are just
from China and Korean, like smurfing.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, that's sad.
- So like, you don't get a game
and then when you get a game,
this guy who's like apparently Iron 1,
like leaps in perfectly like into-
- Oh.
- And you're like,
"All right, okay, fine.
I guess I'm just banned."
- Also, it's like the most toxic server
I've ever experienced.
- Oh, it's so bad.
- Oh my God.
- I kinda wanna try this.
- It's just, 'cause I feel like Asians
are like really rude to each other,
like the different types of Asians.
I've noticed this.
- They are, they are, yes.
- And when a server is full of
people not from that country,
to just like take over that country-
- Oh, bro, it's so bad.
- It becomes a toxic cesspool.
- Yeah.
- You think like any
other "League" server is
toxic, it's nothing compared
to the Japanese server.
- Yeah.
So, Emily and Ditis just moved to Japan,
and Ditis still wants to play "League,"
and he's been sending me screenshots
of like all his chat logs from the game.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- And it's just full on,
just like people going at it,
and arguing.
- That's so interesting.
- It's like no one on the
Japanese servers speaks Japanese.
- Oh!
- Right?
- Yeah, I've never seen Japanese in the...
It's always Chinese or English.
- Korean or English, wow.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, that would
kill my desire too, yeah.
- Yeah, so it's kind of like yeah,
I'm kind of over this so
I just play "TFT" now.
- "TFT's" pretty fun.
- I like "TFT".
- It is fun.
- It's fun.
- But it's such a bad viewer game.
Like, trying to get a new audience
to watch "TFT" is like
welcome to my algebra class 3.
Here's a Morgado, and it's-
- I think it's the best when it's like
a new set just comes out.
That's when the viewership
I think is the best, yeah.
- Because everyone's like
curious and it's like-
- You wanna know, yeah.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I like,
I try to follow "TFT" and I have no idea
what the hell was going on
so it just becomes like,
if they're streaming with a mate,
then it just becomes like a
glorified just chatting stream,
which I can follow.
- Yeah.
- But if it's just
like someone streaming "TFT" I'm like I...
- But even as someone who played it a lot,
I was like Diamond 1
at one point in "TFT,"
- Wow.
- and then the next set
I'm completely clueless.
- Yeah, then you start over.
- So, it's like even if I get really,
really, really good in one set,
I'm completely fuckin' bad
the moment they change everything.
- Right.
- 'Cause like,
everything I learned was
all like muscle memory,
and then I don't know anything.
And now it's really hard
to get back into it.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Guys, have you ever read the fine print
that appears when you start
browsing in incognito mode?
- No.
- [Garnt] Well, it says that,
"Your activity might still
be visible to your employer,
your school or your
internet service provider."
- What?
- How can you
even call that incognito?
To really stop people from
seeing the sites you visit,
you need to do what I
do and use ExpressVPN.
- Think of all the times you've
used wifi at a coffee shop,
a hotel where we are right now
or even at your parents' house.
Without ExpressVPN, every site you visit
could be logged by the
admin of that network,
and in the U.S. where we
currently are right now,
oh, God, they legally sell your data
to other third parties.
- ExpressVPN is an app that encrypts
all your network data and re-routes it
through a network of secure servers
so that your private online activity
stays just that, private.
- So, stop letting strangers
know what you're getting up to.
Go to expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S-V-P-N.com/trashtaste
to get an extra three months for free!
- Thank you the ExpressVPN
for sponsoring the episode.
Back to the show.
- Do you play "Valorant" or?
- I fuckin' hate "Valorant."
- Oh, that's-
- I've had to ban
the word "Valorant."
- 'Cause you're bad?
- Yes.
- Oh.
- I banned the word
"Valorant" in my Twitch chat.
- What, really?
- Really?
- 'Cause people are like,
"Hey, you wanna play "Valorant?
- I'm like, don't fuckin'
ask me if I wanna play that.
This game fuckin' sucks.
All right, let me tell you why
"Valorant" sucks, all right?
Okay?
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
- So, you join this lobby
and you're locked into like an hour.
The game is like an hour.
It's so fuckin' long.
- Is it an hour?
It's not an hour is it?
- Yes, it's like 45 minutes.
- It's 40...
- You're a "League" player,
that's like normal amount.
- No, yeah, but-
- That's a normal amount, right?
- That is pretty normal, yeah.
- Yeah, that's-
- But you're always
gaming in "League," right?
Let's say you join, you're new.
It's like the worst game
to play when you're new,
'cause it's like there's
nothing to keep you engaged.
You go in this game, you
immediately get head shotted
through a wall by like a
12-year-old Korean kid,
and then you're waiting
watching someone else play,
and you're like, oh, dude, nice.
Dude, he carried me, awesome.
- Karma is bad.
- Next round you spend
all your money on a gun, you go out,
you get shot again, you're
like, what the fuck, man?
Let me just play the game.
- I don't know, I feel like "League"
is the worst experience for new players.
That's just me.
- Oh yeah, it's pretty much-
- Because like, "League"-
- I think "League is worse."
- Yeah.
- I tried it once.
- Because like-
- It's horrible.
- With "Valorant" at least
it's a first person shooter.
Everyone knows how to play
first person shooters.
You a point a round,
you click on something
and then it dies or you get killed.
- Yeah, you learn it easier,
I feel.
- Yeah.
- "League" is like, there's,
how many champions are there now?
- Yeah, it's not good.
- Yeah, like if
I didn't play "League" when I was like,
in university there would be no way
I'd be playing "League" now
because the learning curve for that
is fucking ridiculous.
- Yes.
- Okay, would you play "Valorant"
if you had to play it alone, though?
- I play solo queue.
- Do you?
- Sometimes the voice com is hilarious.
- Really?
- I'm like,
"Hey, guys, any mic?"
And they're like, "Shut the fuck up!"
And it's just like, there's content.
- Okay, that's fair.
In Japan no one talks.
- Oh.
- Do you know
the amount of effort I have to do
to get someone to talk
on Japanese voice chat?
- [Lily] Wow.
- On "Apex" I can
sometimes get them to talk.
- It feels like a different like culture.
- They don't talk.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So like, when you play, like I don't know,
did you ever play "Overwatch?"
- Yeah.
Like, in Ranked everyone
used to always talk.
Like, it was like, if
you didn't have a mic,
you were like the guy who's
bringing the team back.
- Okay.
- Right, right.
- Like in Ranked, but then like
the moment I went to Japan,
no on fuckin' uses their mic, ever.
- Wow.
(Joey laughs)
- You have to really like, talk-
- Maybe they're just like, really shy.
- [Guys] They are.
- It's just the culture.
They just don't do it.
Like, it's just not normal to like go-
- That's so interesting.
- This is why Japanese
are like have really bad at esports?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they don't talk?
- They don't communicate,
they can't communicate.
- Their coms are weak, dude.
You ever watch Japanese esports teams?
Their just like, silent.
- Was it the "Valorant" Japanese team?
What's it called?
Do you guys watch-
- They're pretty crap, though.
They're insane.
- They're very good.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Yeah, I don't follow the Japanese
or the "Valorant" esports
team, unfortunately.
Only "League."
- I do.
- That's enough for me.
- They don't talk to each other probably.
- Oh no.
- They probably just like
telepathy or some shit.
- What's your favorite game then?
- That's not "Genshin."
- Eh.
I like "League" just because
I played it for so long
and I started my YouTube
career pretty much on "League,"
so it means a lot to me.
- Yeah.
- But again, it's like you've been dating
this person for like
10 years and it's like-
- It's time to let go.
It's time to-
- It's so (indistinct),
but you do have good times with them.
It's not like you don't
have good times with them.
(guys laughing)
- Sounding real desperate.
"I swear I have a good time them!"
- I assume like, you don't play
Ranked much anymore, right?
- That's when like, I feel
like the game's at its worst.
But also its best in a way.
- I think playing with,
if you have a full stack it could be fun.
- Yeah, agreed.
- But that's the case
with "Valorant" as well.
Full stack, make friends, make things fun.
- Right.
- But "League's" one
of those games as well,
where I feel like if there's one person
in your lobby who's like really
high ranked on your team,
it's really hard to like,
play with them.
- It is. Yeah.
- And it's like, how do you...
I'm not gonna pick my
friends based on their Elo.
Like, I'm not a weirdo.
- Then you just make smurfs.
- Yeah.
- That's what
everyone does, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- Everyone makes smurfs and stuff now.
- Yeah, I mean like, that's kind of like
why I never really get
into competitive games
because there's always
like the initial hump
where you start learning a new game
and it's really fresh, it's really fun,
and then like the moment
that game dies for me
is when I pressed Start
Go on the Ranks ladder.
And then that's when it like,
the game stops from being
fun to just being like
a stressful experience.
- Chore.
- Yeah.
- It's like a friendship ender
at some point.
So, it seems like a
nice idea in your head,
oh yeah, let's Rank up together, guys,
and then like, if you
wanna test your friendship,
you go into a Ranked game
with your friends on "League,"
that will test your friendship, right?
- It's true.
- Because not everyone's
gonna be the same skill level, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so,
you will find out who the toxic people
in your friend group are by
playing Ranked Ladder together.
- True, yeah.
- We are the toxic people.
- [Garnt] Yeah (laughs).
- You do find out.
- It's really...
- Do you like, I don't know, okay.
Have you ever heard of
"Pokemon Puzzle League?"
- "Pokemon Puzzle League?"
- That sounds really familiar.
- Yeah, why does it sound familiar?
- You know "Tetris Attack?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's like that but "Pokemon."
- Oh.
- Is it PC only?
- No, it's-
- Well, what's it got
to do with "Pokemon?"
- It's Nintendo 64.
- [All] Oh!
- Oh, okay, okay.
- It's because I love that game so much,
but no one plays it.
It's like, you know when you have a game-
- Well, yeah, 'cause it was like,
when the dinosaurs were around.
- Okay, but like to this day,
when you go to PAX, or
whatever, some convention,
sometimes they have like
"Tetris Attack" tournaments
and stuff like that even old-
- Oh, that's, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause one of those games
I think I'm like really good at,
but like no one plays.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I stopped playing it.
- Could you still win now?
Would you win if there
was a tournament?
- I think I could win
with some people.
- Did you like "Speedrun?"
- I'm not that good anymore.
- What's the player base
for this game, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's very little.
- It's just Lily.
No one else.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's really-
- There's a free world record
over here.
- There's some people
who still like it,
but they're just scattered so now
I'm trying to like, get
better at "Valorant,"
'cause everyone plays "Valorant," right?
- Yeah.
- So, if you're good
at "Valorant," you'll look cool, man.
- [Garnt] I just wanna look cool.
- I just wanna be cool but I can't.
I'm not good at PS.
I'm good at like music rhythm games
or stuff like that,
- Yeah, right.
- but like, that's not cool.
"Valorant's" cool right now.
- Just come to Japan,
it's really far from cool in Japan.
- I am very excited to go to all
of the arcades.
- Just go to the arcade
and just master a rhythm game,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- and you will be like, the
princess of that arcade.
- But then you realize how shit
you are when you go to Japan.
You see so many people-
- I do agree, I do agree.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've seen-
- You just see
those motherfuckers on
Tune In, they're just...
- I've seen them and they're like,
it's so real.
- It's like clockwork.
- But it's like they're all like that.
- Yeah, I know.
- Every time you go,
everyone is like serious about it.
- Everyone has like, their custom gear.
Like, you go to one of the booths
and they bring out the
fucking glove or something.
And you're like, God damn!
- They take it really serious.
It's like when they go to like,
you know like DDR or Pump It Up machines?
- Yeah.
- They come with
like towels and water bottles
and like backpacks and-
- Yeah.
- Like they're camping the-
- Oh my God.
- You know shit's about
to get like fucked up when like the...
It's always like, it's never the guys
who are like fully, fully in
shape that are the best at DDR.
It's like the guys who are like
just come out to the
arcade just to play DDR.
- Big dudes tear it up.
- There's some
big dudes I've seen.
I remember this like, one
kind of like larger gentlemen
in Osaka who just went
up to a DDR machine,
like huge bottle of water,
big towel, and he looked like
he was about to work out,
- Wow.
- and everyone at that arcade
was like, "Hold on, guys."
- Let's get gone.
- Something magical's
about to happen.
- Yeah.
- He was absolutely tearing ass
and there's like 30 people surrounding him
just being like,
- That's so cool.
- "I will challenge you."
And he's just like, "All right.
Step up."
- Honestly, it's sometimes
intimidating though,
'cause sometimes I just wanna like try out
a nice rhythm game.
- Yeah.
- You should try.
- No, I do love the rhythm games,
but like sometimes you see someone
like tear it up in this rhythm game
and I'm just like I don't
know how to get it to start.
Like (laughs).
- They sucked too in the beginning.
- That's me with like, fighting
games, though at arcades.
- Oh.
- 'Cause it's like,
I always wanna try it, but there's always
a fuckin' prodigy 10 year old
on the other side ready
to kick my ass, right?
- Also, they smoke at those in Japan.
- Really?
- Oh, yeah, that's true.
- Oh, at some of them they do.
- A lotta the ones for the fighting games,
on the floor you can smoke on the floor.
- Especially like
the old school ones.
- The old school arcades.
- The old school ones.
- Yeah,
the old school arcades.
- I can't even smell it.
- It'll be like,
no smoke on any of the floor,
the fighting game floor you can smoke.
There'll be
ashtrays and stuff.
- You can smoke.
- And so, just it wreaks of smoke, though.
- But in the middle of that,
there's always that one 10-year-old
who's just destroying everyone.
- [Garnt] Yeah (laughs).
- It's really interesting.
I feel like you see an almost
authentic side of Japan
in the arcade.
You kinda see like everyone
kinda just like come
into this place and
just let off some steam.
- Yeah.
- It's really interesting.
- It's the best.
- Yeah,
I think like the fighting game community
in Japan is like, way
bigger than say like,
what's like-
- "Smash."
- I don't know, is "Smash" big in Japan?
I don't know about that.
- It was big.
- Right.
- At the peak, I think.
- Like, there was a lot
of like high level competitors going
to like big "Smash"
tournaments in the U.S.,
at like EVO and shit,
- Right.
- but I don't know about now.
- I don't know, in any game where
you don't need to converse with someone
to be good at it.
- Ah.
- Like, that's like big in Japan.
- Yeah, sure.
- So, rhythm games,
fighting games is like massive in Japan.
- No words necessary, only fists.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's just like
'cause they wanna do one thing
and they just wanna perfect it.
It's a very Japanese way of thinking.
- Yeah.
- It's like,
I just wanna re-do this same thing
and just get very good at this one skill.
- Not to prove it to anyone,
just to prove it to myself.
- It's like a self rewarding feeling.
I'm not really sure why.
Like it's kind of-
- It's very zen.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is kinda how it works.
- Yeah, it's zen.
- Yeah, like I really want
to get into fighting games,
but they're such a big, massive jump
from just randomly mashing buttons,
to like being even
- Yeah, learning combos.
- like a competent like,
like being just mildly
competent at fighting games.
That's such a big fucking gap.
- It's hard.
I'm just getting better at "Smash"
because I just wanted to
beat the people at the party.
You know how at the party
there's always a "Smash" set up?
- [Guys] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I just wanted to
beat like, some people.
That was my threshold.
- Did you ever get to that point?
- I don't know.
There were no parties, COVID hit.
(all laughing)
- It's like all the
training gone to waste.
- Yeah.
- I think the only time,
'cause Joey's like one of
the chillest guys I know,
I think one of the only times
I've seen Joey like
genuinely tilted and angry
is during "Smash"
- Was "Smash."
- when he played Connor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause this motherfucker
kept playing "King K. Rool"
and just fuckin' down being every time.
- I love characters with counters.
It feels so fun.
It's like why would I wanna hit you
when I can make you hit yourself?
- It's the only time I've
ever thrown a controller
on the ground.
- Oh.
- I'm just like, fucking!
- There's something about "Smash."
The other day I was on YouTube,
and there's like these
whole "Smash" compilations.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're my favorite.
- They're so funny.
- It's like this whole world opened up
and I just started clicking
for like three hours.
It was fun.
- Like, the saltiest moment
compilations of "Smash"
- Yes!
- tournaments are the
funniest things ever.
- I thought that was like one
of Ludwig's most popular videos,
is that he made a compilation
- Is it?
- of like, "Top 10 Saltiest
Ice Climber Moments" I think.
- Really (laughs)?
- Yeah.
- And that's like his most popular video.
- I didn't even know he made that video.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, like,
part of the reasons I wanna
get into fighting games
'cause the fighting game
community just seems so fun.
- Yeah-
- Like I've seen
like so many compilations on YouTube
or just like fighting game
community moments and it's just,
I don't know how I can describe it.
It's the perfect mix
of just cancer toxicity
but also like no one takes
it too seriously as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's very passionate.
- They're very passionate.
- There's a really funny clip,
I think it was a "Street Fighter
2" tournament or something
at like some convention
and it's just like two people fighting
a huge crowd and this kid
just gets absolutely fuckin' destroyed.
And just from the back,
just some guy just goes,
"Get the boy some milk!"
And then it just became a thing
in the fighting game community
as like a thing to just
be like, "He's tilted.
Give that boy some milk."
- 'Cause like, gaming now, right?
It's very like, it's been
kind of like, polished a bit.
You can't trash talk as much online.
It's really frowned upon.
- You'll be canceled.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then now,
but like that's why I feel like
the fighting game is such a cool place.
It's like, you just trash talk.
- Yeah.
- That's what it's all about.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly, right?
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- It's kinda like a real
UFC fight or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Where people are trash talking
and it's like,
- That's awesome.
- it's part of like, the
entertainment, right?
- Like, safe trash talking for nerds.
(all laughing)
- And no one gets hurt.
- I love it, I love that.
I miss trash talk on video games.
- Yeah.
- I like that.
- Do you not do that
anymore on like, "League?"
- I can't now.
Like, watch one of my films, matey.
- What about "Apex?"
What about "Apex?"
- Oh, "Apex?" Yeah, I would.
Yeah, I love trash talking as well.
- Do you trash talk, Lily?
- No.
I like I'd say oo method.
So like, in "Valorant" when
they're like really mean to me,
I just type oo oo like...
It pisses them off, it's really funny.
Like, "Oo, are you talking to me?"
(all laughing)
- Oh, God.
It's like somehow more aggravating.
- It is-
- That's worse
than trash talk.
I mean-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's nasty.
- I feel bad saying like,
"Yeah, you're shit,"
that just feels weird.
- No, no, that's unoriginal.
You have to come up
with like, fun insults.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's hard.
I'm trying to focus on the game,
how can I think of witty insults?
Like...
- I mean, in "Valorant," right?
You're dead for like most of the time.
I'm here just like, spit ballin' ideas.
I'm trying to like test these ideas.
I'm messaging friends
like, "What do you think?"
Oh, I'm out. Oh no, I'm dead.
- He's going deep
into the insult book.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm just that guys who's just like,
"Let's try our best, guys."
We can win this.
- Oh, yeah.
That's why I don't play call
games 'cause I'm that guy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're just like,
"Shut up, pussy!"
(all laughing)
- I will say one thing
I hate about "Valorant"
is that why is like one skin
for a gun fuckin' like 30 bucks?
What's up with that?
- They're a small company.
They need to make money somehow.
- Small? Small company.
- Small company.
- That was the one thing that
I was like, what the fuck?
Even "League" isn't this bad.
I mean, "League" sometimes.
They have nice skin.
- Have you seen
their prestige skins?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, okay,
those are pretty gross.
- Yikes.
- You remember "Elementalist Lux?"
- Yeah, yeah, that's was like 4,000?
- $30?
- Yeah, it was a lot.
- Yeah, so I was like-
- That was 30 bucks?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- For one skin, for one skin?
- So expensive.
- Yeah.
- But it's like a...
Okay, it's not just one skin,
it's like 10 skins in one.
- In the game you can change to an element
and it changes the whole skin.
- You can change
to an element. And you can
change it to another element
and those elements mixed,
it makes another element.
And there's 10 in total and each one
has different voice lines,
so it's actually 10 skins in one.
- Does it change anything
about the way the character's played?
- No, no, no.
- No.
- 'Cause if it did then it wouldn't,
it would break the game.
- It's just like aesthetic.
- So, yeah, so it's just
a really elaborate aesthetic choice?
- Yeah, but it's really pretty.
It's my favorite champion.
I was really excited so I got it
and I asked my friend, "Do you want one?"
I think everyone should try it, right?
So I gave him one, and then
I asked another friend,
I'm like, "Do you want one too?"
I spent, I gave like five friends
like "Elementalist Lux."
- Oh my God.
- Okay?
(Lily sighs)
- Yolo rent.
- Another reason to not play.
- I used to always get
the 490 mystery skins,
where you played the 490.
- Oh no (laughs)!
- I used to love that.
I don't know, I'm just-
- Was it like a mystery box?
- It's a mystery box.
- So, wait,
are you telling me-
- You're playing gacha.
- You were into gacha?
Are you telling me you were into gacha?
- 'Cause I wanted skins
but I didn't wanna feel
like I was paying full price,
'cause if I did that I would feel ashamed.
- So you got a skin
that you probably didn't
even play, really.
- What do you mean?
I love one of the Udyr skins
that isn't Spirit Guard Udyr.
I love those.
When you get a skin from malphite
and it would be like the...
You know he has that one, what
is it? Like the shamrock one?
That one is so fuckin'-
- Oh, shamrock malphite.
Yeah.
- They would like,
just re-color him green and be like,
"Look, it's shamrock."
But he was just rock.
- That was like,
early "League" skins.
They just recolored it and
called it something else,
but nowadays-
- It's just
a shiny Pokemon isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- They have stepped it up.
- Yeah, I mean now everyone just looks...
But all the girls now, they
make them look the same
in like every skin.
It's kinda weird.
- Yeah, I know but they're so pretty.
I know about this, but like
my eyes are glazed over
when I see like, sparkles
and pretty colors.
- Is the skins what makes you
come back to play "League"
whenever like a new
skin like gets released
and you're like, "Damn, that looks good."
- I do only play cute champions.
I'm not gonna lie.
- That's all right.
- That does check out,
that does check out.
- I feel like I know the answer to this,
but obviously as someone who's
been doing "League" stuff
for a really long time,
"League" is kind of going more
in like, an anime direction.
- [Lily] I noticed.
- Do you like that?
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah?
- I think they should
just go full weeb honestly at this point.
Just do it.
- I do wish they had a
little more monsters, though.
I do like the monsters a lot.
- There's monsters.
Did you see that mummy (indistinct)?
- [Garnt] But they're not
pretty to look at. I mean-
- The-
- Zac is like
my favorite character.
- Oh, he's like a big bubblegum.
- He's just great, he's fun.
I love how he plays.
He's great.
- I agree.
But I think it's also what sells,
so I think all Star Guardian like...
- Yeah, Yasuo's and all those kind
- Pretty skins.
- of Samurai warriors.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
"League" and weeb culture are all,
"Leagues" and weebs have always like,
just meshed one to one.
- I agree.
- "Leagues" and weebs.
- Yeah, "Leagues" and weebs, right?
- It's like leave weebs in
the middle and Sue over here.
- Yeah, leave Sue.
Oh, see, you get deep if you're Sue.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah, because like, I
remember even before like,
in the early days of "League,"
pretty much everyone who played "League"
I felt watched anime as well,
'cause like I see so many people
like just talking about anime in my chat
when I would play "League."
And I was like, "Oh, this is
where all the anime fans are,"
because I couldn't find them in real life.
They're all playing "League".
- [Lily] They're all playing "League".
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you'd think
it'd be like Hisokafan69 or something,
is like the name and
you're like, all right.
- (laughs) 'Cause everyone
was playing Yasuo, right?
And you know that if you're a Yasuo player
you definitely watch anime.
- I found the word Yasuo in my chat-
- Did you?
- When you type in Yasuo
it's an email of someone puking.
(all laughing)
- Really?
- I hate that champion.
I firmly believe that him being created
like dampened my game experience
and made me play like, less.
I hate Yasuo.
- You make it sound like-
- I think, no,
what's his brother called?
- I hate Yone.
- Yone.
- I think Yone's
way worse than Yasuo.
- No, I know.
It's like they took everything
that was bad about Yasuo and they like,
they made it even worse in Yone.
I hate those two champions so much.
Like, every time I see it I
don't even wanna play anymore.
- So, to explain Yasuo to you, Joey.
- Yeah, please.
- Oh, right, sorry.
- Okay, Yasuo is a Samurai,
right?
- That's it.
- He's a very high skill
cap Samurai champion, right?
- [Lily] "High skill cap."
- So, huh?
- No, sorry.
"High skill cap," is just
a really funny way to...
- How would you say it?
- He's a character you wanna play
when you wanna be like, edgy.
Like you wanna be flashy and shit.
- Everyone wants to be
better than they are-
- Yeah.
- Which is very, he is
a difficult character.
- Right.
- He is, okay,
he is pretty hard to fight.
- Okay, so like,
how it always plays out is when
you are against an enemy Yasuo,
they'll like fuckin' God mode Yasuo.
They will go, like they
will fuckin' solo kill
your entire team and like make
you sort of lose the game,
but when a Yasuo's on your team,
it's guaranteed by like
the force of nature
that they'll be the
reason you lose the game.
- You're shit?
- Yeah.
- They'll go 0 and 10,
and then they'll flame everyone
for like sucking at the game, right?
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Yasuo plays like, the worst basically.
- And then they made
a brother called Yone.
It's like his same skill-
- It's the same thing but
with a bunch of more bullshit.
- Yeah, it's insane.
- Even more like,
weird shit, self healing, more shields.
- Yeah, when it came
out I was like in shock.
I'm like, I don't have two bans.
I only have one.
(guys laughing)
So, I feel like I have to ask
my friends, ban Yone for me.
- Yeah, I mean, all the new characters
they release are nuts.
Like, I just, like...
- Yeah, yeah, I think it's-
- I hate Zoe, I hate Taliyah,
even though that's old now,
but like-
- Taliyah's kind of old, yeah.
- Taliyah's very old.
- Yeah, yeah.
I know, I know, but like ever since like,
that point onwards I've just kinda like...
- I do think like, as
"League" gets bigger,
they have like over 160 champions.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- Like, there's only
so many kits they can make and like,
how are you gonna make each
one more unique, I guess?
- Yeah, it definitely feels like
they keep making it even
crazier and crazier,
like the new one they announced
looked just like stupid.
- Yeah.
- Did you see it?
- The water girl?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I don't-
- Fuckin' like dashing
like everywhere, like
even more than normal now.
- Yeah.
- Or what's the...
Samira's as well, I didn't really like.
I'm like what the fuck
- I don't know.
- is Samira doing?
- I've never played.
- Who's Samira again?
- Yeah, there's-
- Some Irish girl with-
- Oh, yeah.
- They carried.
- There's too many.
- Yeah, it's-
- There's so many.
- Joey looks so lost right now.
- There's like 160.
- I'm just vibin', dude.
- Joey's just vibin' right now.
- [Joey] I'm just vibin'.
It's all good.
- Yeah, because like the only way
I find out about "League" champions now
is 'cause when I followed
the esports scene
and I see a "League"
champion and I just like,
I have no idea what this person does.
- Oh my God, they picked
it, they picked a thing,
and you're like oh, so, what is it?
I don't know, sue me in the game.
- Do you still follow
the esports scene at all?
- Nah.
- Why would you?
You're from the NA server, right?
- Well...
(guys laughing)
I said it okay, I said it.
- You're not wrong.
I do think back in the day,
like I'm talking like season three, four,
there were more story
lines that I could follow.
Like, you knew everyone.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like TSM or whatever.
Now it's like, I just lost track.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
- Yeah.
Pretty much you just like,
follow Faka and-
- I can't believe Faka
is still like playing.
- I know.
I wonder what's gonna
happen when he retires.
- He's like the God of "League
of Legends" at this point.
That's insane.
- So, Faka's like I
guess, what's it called?
Like, the Michael Jordan
of like, "League," I guess.
That's like, what like-
- The Michael Jordan
of "League."
- Yeah, I mean,
it's fair enough.
- I mean like, I'm
trying to think of like,
a really, a really-
- Like a really great player?
- Yeah, yeah.
- He's super skilled.
He's like notorious for being really-
- I've heard the name Faka.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because his name I guess,
almost like transcends "League" itself
because you might not know
nothing about "League"
but you've heard the name Faka now.
- I know the name Faka, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, I think he chose
such a good name too to be like,
that icon like faker.
It sounds so cool.
- I can't watch his streams, though.
It makes me sick watching
him like, with the camera.
- I haven't.
- He whips the camera
all around.
- Oh.
- It's like impossible
to watch, yeah.
- What?
- He like flicks around everywhere
and it's nauseating to watch.
- Yeah, so he has like, hot keys.
So, he has hot keys
where he can like flick
to like different champions
or like his team mates-
- He uses those?
- Yeah, yeah, he uses them,
- Yeah.
- but he flicks to like,
a team mate for like a micro second,
and somehow that's enough
- Like, boom, boom.
- time to garner the information he needs.
- That's insane.
- I'm just like,
this is what happens when you're like,
just jacked into the matrix (laughs).
- Was it you talking about this edit
where like it's someone where like
he's in a fight and instead of flicking,
someone edited so he's
opening up Solitaire?
(all laughing)
He's playing like,
Solitaire while fighting.
It's so good 'cause it looks real.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's so good.
- Yeah, but like, yeah, I
can't watch his streams,
but like pretty much-
- You speak "Jump King"?
- Huh?
- I've been "Jump King".
- Oh, you "Jump King".
- While playing "League" as well?
- Probably.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, just switching
"League" and "Jump King".
(all laughing)
- Gonna jump flick back to "League".
- I hate "Jump," I couldn't beat it.
- It's great watching him play,
"Jump King" and "Pogostuck"
'cause you're like, you are human.
It's nice to-
- You're not a God gamer.
- You seem him fall a
shit ton in "Jump King"
and you're like that's really comforting.
- Right.
- The best guy
in the world at this game also struggled
at that one fucking jump
on "Jump King" like I did.
- Yeah.
Have you finished "Jump King"?
- No. I uninstalled it.
- I haven't, yeah.
- So you both need to finish.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, I'm probably never
gonna touch that game.
It reminded me of that other game.
- What?
- It's a game like that.
- [Connor and Garnt] "Getting Over it?"
- Yes!
- Yes.
- No, no,
"Jump King's" way harder.
- "Jump King's" way harder.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they're both
hard and they both get,
I gave up on both of them.
- I love "Jump King".
- But it's like, somehow "Jump King,"
even though it's like a rage game,
is still like less-
- We always come back to it.
- Still like less rage inducing
to me then some "League" servers.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Or some "League" games.
- I must say, it was definitely
one of the most satisfying
moments when I beat that game.
- I bet.
- In recent history.
- That accomplishment.
- Yeah.
It was really good.
- Would you do the expansions, though?
- No.
I prioritize my happiness.
(Garnt laughs)
So, no thank you.
I say that and I'm probably going to.
It's like a drug.
- Yeah.
- That was the worst
carpal tunnel I ever got
from playing "Jump King."
I've never gotten carpal tunnel before.
- Oh my gosh.
- Well, 'cause you play
with a keyboard, right?
- Yeah, I do that, yes.
- I play with controller.
- Oh, that's-
- Like, it's-
- That's smart.
- Yeah, I shoulda done that.
I'm fuckin' dumb.
- That's okay,
at least you watch "Arcane."
- Yeah, yeah, at least
I did watch "Arcane."
That's true.
- I'm so sorry.
I can't believe you didn't watch it.
It's so good.
- I can't believe it's brought up again.
- You have a TV.
We should watch it here.
- Well, I mean, this is the only TV-
- This is the only TV in the-
- Oh.
- Yeah.
- Unfortunately, somehow we have this
like fuckin' mansion
in LA and this is like,
it's only got
- One TV in the house.
- one TV and no curtains.
- This is a beautiful place.
You guys picked a nice place.
- Thank you.
- You guys want to like,
stay in comfort.
- Yeah.
- Who doesn't wanna stay in comfort?
- My Uber was driving and like,
the neighborhoods were
getting nicer and nicer.
(all laughing)
- Every Uber driver that's
dropped me off here is like,
"What do you do for work?"
- Yeah, like I brought up my
map and I'm like, where are we?
(all laughing)
It's really nice.
- But then I feel the obligation
to have to tip way more than normal
'cause they're like, "Oh, what do you do?"
And I'm like, "No, no-"
- Oh, you should say I'm a YouTuber.
- No, do you tell people that?
- Hell no.
This is how the conversation goes.
Like, "Oh, do you work?"
I'm like, "No, no, no."
"Oh, what do you do?" I'm
like, "Oh, I work from home."
"Oh, like what do you do from home?"
"Oh, I just like make videos."
"Oh, like on YouTube?"
- Oh, no.
- But it's like,
but it leads up to that and I'm like,
I need to just think of a
different profession every time.
- I was talking to an Uber driver
'cause he was kinda like a,
he seemed like a really interesting dude.
- Yeah.
- Quite a character I'd say.
And so I just started asking him questions
'cause I really wanted to
hear his opinion on things,
and he's from LA of course when you're
a strange person I feel like
you're born and raised here.
I was like, I just asked him a few things.
First of all, I was
like, "Do you like LA?"
He's like, "Fuck no."
I was like, "Oh, why do you live here?"
He's like, "Man, I don't know.
I can't leave, man." And
I was like, "All right."
- That's what they all say, though.
- That's what everyone says.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He was like,
"I wanna move to Miami
and become a YouTuber."
- Oh!
- I was like,
"Yeah, man, what kinda
videos would you make?"
He's like, "Just ratin' chicks."
(all laughing)
Okay, I was like, "What do you mean?"
He's like, "Just say how the
girls are, talk about them."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like,
"You'd make a whole channel
about rating women?"
- Just rating women, really?
- Your adventures with them?
He's like, "Yeah, dude."
- Yeah, yeah.
- But have you ever heard of
the channel Prank Invasion?
- [Connor] Yeah (laughs).
- Ain't that the same thing?
- It's so...
I was like, all right, I was like...
- Where do you even begin with this?
- Yeah, I didn't even
wanna begin unpacking it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
what do I even do?
- You just say like-
- You already got like
one Uber driver's worth of time
to like unpack everything.
- I was like, "Do you ever think that LA
should have like more public transport?"
He's like, "Fuck no, man."
- What?
- I was like, "What do
you think it needs?"
He's like, "We need more e-scooters."
And I was like (laughs)...
- Okay.
- And I'd be like,
it's a great idea.
That's fantastic.
- Honestly,
those scooters are really fun.
- Honestly, honestly, I
think it fuckin' works
in cities where it has an
infrastructure for cycling
'cause I recently went to Belgium,
and like using the
e-scooters in Belgium was,
it was one, really, really fun,
and two, really, really
fucking convenient as well.
- Right, right.
- Like, because we, me
and Sydney got our station
and we tried to like, find a taxi,
and like the fuckin' line for the taxi
was like a fuckin' mile
long, I swear to God.
'Cause there were just not enough roads
and not enough taxis to
accommodate everyone.
- Right.
- So, we were looking
at what everyone was doing
and everyone was either
cycling or just e-scooting.
So-
- That's so nice.
- Yeah.
- I wish LA was more
like friendly to just like,
e-scooters, cycling, trains, buses.
Like, in general that we didn't
have to rely on cars so much.
It feels like if you don't
have a car in LA you're fucked.
- Yeah, 'cause wasn't there this big craze
of just people who were
trashing e-scooters here?
Or just like throwing them
into the river or something?
- Yeah, there was a, yeah.
- They are like-
- I think they're still doing it.
- Huh?
- They're probably
still doing it.
- They are ugly.
- Yeah, because like, I
get it if you leave it on
the street just on like
the pavement or whatever,
- You just leave it, yeah.
- Right?
- You shouldn't do that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, in Brussels everyone was leaving
it where people parked their bikes.
- Yeah.
- So you just go
to like a designated section.
- Asking Americans to be that considerate?
- Yes.
(Garnt laughing)
- Last cause.
- In San Francisco they have like rental,
like it's the same concept where
you use your phone to unlock
but they unlock mopeds.
- Oh, mopeds?
- Yeah, it was sick.
We just rode mopeds around San Francisco.
- You don't need a
license to drive a moped?
- I don't know, Michael did it for me.
I just hopped on.
(all laughing)
- That does sound sick though,
that does sound sick.
- I don't know
what I'm saying.
- It was so fun. Like,
if you unlock the back,
they come with two helmets
'cause they know people
would like to ride someone.
- Oh, that's cool.
- It was so convenient.
- That's really fucking convenient.
- Yeah.
- It'd be nice if I had like other options
that wasn't Uber and Lyft.
That's our public transportation.
And these days it's really
hard to get Uber and Lyft
'cause the prices went up and like,
it was hard getting one to come here.
- Yeah, it's really expensive.
Like, how do you get around normally?
- Me?
- Like if you-
- I just don't leave my apartment.
- Do you drive?
- No.
- Can you drive?
(Garnt chuckles)
- Do you have a license?
- I mean, I have a car.
- Oh, I see.
- I see.
- Right, right, right.
- Okay.
- It's my brother's car.
- That would be cool to-
- We share the car.
- We call it a paper license in Japan.
- Yeah.
- But I don't like driving.
- I don't like driving either,
especially like driving here,
it seems so stressful here.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like really panicky.
I think I'm doing other people
a favor by not going on the road.
You're welcome.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm saving your life.
- Everyone seems like a
really bad driver here.
- Yeah, there's a lot of road rage stuff.
I just, I don't trust myself.
- A lot of people just
get super fucking angry
and like immediately over
like a mild inconvenience.
Like, someone will like make them so mad.
- [Joey] 'Cause they don't wanna be here.
- They're like (imitates horn honking).
- Because they don't wanna be here.
- They don't wanna be here.
- That's the same people
where you go, "Do you like LA?"
And they go, "Fuck no."
- Honestly, LA, you just live here
for like the people, connection, whatever.
Voice over is here too for me,
but it's like if I had to
pick somewhere to live,
it would not be LA.
- Honestly like, I get it because I would
not wanna spend any more time on the road
in LA then I need to.
Like, being in LA traffic here,
I like, I experienced it for
the first time the other day.
I'm like, "Oh, this is why
every LA person complains about traffic."
It's like a piece of your soul
just like gets lost every time
you get stuck on the highway.
- Boys, it's the season of summer,
the season of the sand, the sun, the sea,
and most importantly
(speaking in Japanese).
- What is (speaking Japanese)?
- Isn't that like the test of courage
you see in anime where
the high school girls
go to a haunted place?
- You're absolute right, Garnt.
And yeah, apparently it's supposed
to chill you down to the bone
so you don't feel as hot as you do.
- Does it work?
- No idea, 'cause I'm a little girl
and I don't go on those things,
but I can tell you one
thing that will work.
- What?
- That's the sponsor for
this video, "Bloodline."
- [Connor and Garnt] Oo!
- [Garnt] "Bloodline
The Last Royal Vampire"
is a fast paced retro style mobile JRPG,
a vampire themed card game
in a modern fantasy setting.
- [Joey] "Bloodline" is a nice
mix of anime style cut ins
and (indistinct) style battle effects.
It's a classic JRPG for strategic
and team building aspects on top
of quick stylish animated action.
Tons to do so you'll never get bored.
- The story is immersive
with endless gameplay
content, epic boss battles,
PVP battles and over 400
characters you can summon
to create the ultimate team.
So, what are you waiting for?
Go check out "Bloodline The
Last Royal Vampire" now.
Link's in the description.
- Back to the episode.
- All right.
- (indistinct) kiddos.
- There was some real
- I agree.
- depression in that.
- Yes.
(Garnt chuckles)
- It's the 10 years on Twitch.
- Is it 10 years on Twitch as well?
My God.
- Yeah,
this year, well, this month or next month
is my 10th partnered year on Twitch.
- Oh my God.
- Damn.
- Not including like livestream.com,
just on dot TV, own dot TV.
Like, I've dabbled in that before.
- You sound exhausted
- Wow.
- just saying that.
(all laughing)
- Are you ashamed
of your past?
- I can hear like
a decade worth of PTSD coming out.
- Oh my God, can you?
There is.
(all laughing)
10 years worth of like...
Imagine being little 19 year old Lily
with high voice, girl on internet,
the comments you would get like,
when you just start out when like,
it's not as common.
- Yeah.
- (groans) I needed therapy.
(Garnt laughs)
- Now I'm good, now
I'm a well functioning,
happy, healthy adult.
- How did you, I mean,
get over it I guess?
- You just gotta, what
are you gonna do, die?
- No, I mean-
- Guess we'll die.
- Some people are like, "Fuck,
I can't do this anymore,"
and they quit.
- Yeah, it's essentially that.
It's like you either quit or you
just keep going and then you're like,
I'll just keep going,
see where it leads me."
At this point it's like,
what other life skills do I have?
Let's be honest, I'm a streamer.
- What about like music full time?
- It's hard to make money
off music full time.
I'm learning, I do make like music.
I upload them on streaming services.
But it's, like full
time, it's really hard.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's super hard.
So, I think streaming on YouTube's
is like a good way to supplement what
you really want to do.
- Yeah.
- All the producer costs or
like, voice acting classes
or stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- I mean, you dabble in a lot of things
as we have established at the beginning,
so I think that's a good kinda lifestyle.
- Yeah, I think it's very good.
Like, I think I'm super privileged.
Like, I'm very thankful I can do this
'cause everyone wants to be a streamer
or like a content creator.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and I did start
when there were not many.
- Yeah.
- So, I think I did get
a lucky in that sense.
Like, do you think if you started now
with absolutely nothing,
you could make it?
- Oh God, hell no.
- Right?
- I mean, like the bar
- It's hard to say.
- of quality now is so much higher.
- It's so much higher.
- Probably spend $100,000
on every video with like-
- But like, it's insane.
Like, back then I feel like
it was so much easier
'cause more visibility,
less saturation.
- Yeah.
- But also I think when you're,
let's say you come in now,
now what you do, like your baseline
of what you expect and what you think
of how to make a video is probably
gonna be better because
everyone else is also better.
I feel like back then everyone was bad,
because there was no frame of reference
of what good is.
- Yeah, no one knew what
they were doing back then.
- Yeah, it was-
- Like, "Equals Three"
was the biggest fuckin' show on YouTube.
Have you tried watching "Equals Three?"
It sucks.
(all laughing)
- It didn't age well.
- It is bad.
- Yeah.
- Like, and that was like
the biggest thing on YouTube
and like that's weird,
but I feel like-
- I remember when
I used to watch that shit, man.
- Yeah.
- It was great.
- I feel like the formula was there,
you just removed all the commentary,
but now you have like
"Daily Dose of Internet."
- Yeah.
- Which is basically
like the same thing.
- Or meme compilations.
- Or there's meme compilations, right?
I feel like there was something
there with "Equals Three"
and then you-
- Yeah, but the bar
always changes, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, someone brings
something or someone adds something like,
like MrBeast has like changed
how everyone makes YouTube videos.
- Yeah.
- His style has made it like-
- That's insane.
- YouTube changed
over the past two years
more than I've ever seen it,
like ever.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause of the style of like...
Now everyone talks at like 5,000 words
per minute and screams.
- And I still have to
watch it at 1.5 speed.
- Okay, wow.
- How do you watch that at 1.5 speed?
- So, my problem is I like,
when I wanna digest
information I prefer reading.
I read very fast.
I can like, read really fast
but when they're talking
it's like please,
- You hate that
it's slower?
- Faster.
- Sometimes you just need
to digits the information.
- Faster so I like, I go
to 1.5 and I'm like yes!
And I have the subtitle thingy on.
That's what I like.
- Oh.
- Jesus.
- I get it, I get it.
- You're just like,
unbuffing yourself.
(Garnt laughs)
Just like, you know what?
This is too easy.
I'm gonna make it hard on myself.
- Some people just speak
too fuckin' slow, man.
- Yeah, some people-
- All those years,
I was like reading Reddit paid off.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- Dude, I warned my friends,
if you have chat logs open on your phone
and I glance at it, I will read it.
Like, I can't help it.
So, please point it away.
(all laughing)
- What are you, like a
fuckin' fiend for words?
You're like, "I just gotta read something!
Fuck!"
- It's like, I like reading so...
Oh my God, there was one time,
it was really funny, I
told this story already.
We're in a car, Scarra's
in the front seat, right?
He sent a DM with this girl-
- [Connor and Garnt] Right.
- I'm gonna make a name.
Give me a name.
- Barbara.
- Barbara. Okay.
He's in the car with this Barbara,
and the reflection from his DM
was in the car window.
I read that and I'm like,
"So, who's Barbara, Scarra?"
And he was so shocked.
He's like, "What's wrong with you?"
- That's fuckin' creepy.
If I turn around and you're like,
"Connor who is..."
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Because it was like far away,
but then like the reflection
from the front window,
I could read everything.
I'm like, no, I'm just
warning you, like just-
- I'm scared to pull my credit
card out in front of you now.
Like-
- I'm not interested.
- She just scans it in.
- I'm not interested in your credit card.
I think chat logs and stuff like that
are most interesting 'cause like,
I feel like I learn a lot about people
how you type when you
think no one's reading.
- Yeah.
- Sorry, that sounds really creepy.
- That's so scary (laughs).
- I have like, not exactly the same thing
but so do you play Wordle at all?
- Wordle.
- Yeah.
- I love Wordle.
- Watching someone play Wordle
is actually really fucking
entertaining to see
how their mind words and just like
what guesses they make.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, I remember we were in like
a long road trip or something,
and just like Joey was playing Wordle
in like the front seat and me and Connor
were just like silently judging
commentating in the back.
- Well, 'cause you were
typing words that weren't real
and we all do it.
- Yeah, because-
- and everyone does it,
but it's fun to be like,
"Oh, you really think like,
flubble is a word?"
- It gets to the point
where you're just like,
this has to be a word I don't know.
'cause you just start typing,
randomly doing it.
- Sometimes it is.
- And I hate it when
people are watching you
'cause I'm just like, "Don't judge me.
I know this isn't a real word."
- No, we all do it, but like
it's so entertaining watching
someone else do it.
It's like, you fuckin' idiot.
- Yeah, that's not a real word.
- With Wordle, I thought
the tactic was like,
I have like three words I always use.
Two, like two.
- Yeah, I do as well.
- Now it's just that.
- I've stopped doing that now-
- But unless it's boring.
- Yeah.
- That's a good point.
- I just go with like, my
whatever I feel like now.
Joey's still on like, the
fuckin' crane meta, like-
- Yeah, I think the crane meta works.
- I don't play Wordle anymore.
I gave up.
- Yeah, that was such
a big thing.
Everyone on Twitter was
posting their little squares.
Like, what is that?
- I feel like I missed the train.
I was very late to it,
'cause I was too scared to
ask what the squares were.
- Aw.
I get that.
- You were too scared to ask?
- Yeah, I was like, is this
like some cult or something
that people are coming into or?
- I felt the same way so I would click
on the replies of the squares
'cause people will ask
and then I get the answer.
- Yeah, right, right.
See, I wasn't smart enough.
- Like, once I started
playing it, you could tell.
Like, there was some people on your feed
that are just like, you are cheating.
I know you're
fucking cheating.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This word progression
makes zero fuckin' sense.
And you'd see them, like
they'd try to like, mix it up.
Sometimes they'd get like threes and four,
but they get too many
twos to be like really,
to be like universally make sense.
I know you guys are out there.
I know, stop doing it.
- The Wordle cheaters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why, why?
I can tell, okay?
We can all tell.
- To look cool on social media.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's all I want.
- No one's ever thought,
"Wow, you're good at Wordle?
That's so fuckin' hot."
(all laughing)
- Okay.
- Slide into my DMs right now.
- Do you got the two?
- I'm breakin' up.
- (groans) Dude.
- Yeah, I guess you're right.
- Come on, like getting a two naturally
is fuckin' like, oh, it's so satisfying.
It's so fuckin' satisfying.
Why would you fake that?
- That phase ended pretty quickly.
I don't see it anymore.
- Yeah, I think that was online.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- That is, yeah, trends
online just, it's so-
- It moves too fast now.
- Yeah.
- So fast.
Is "It's Morbin' time" funny still?
- I don't know, by the time this out, no.
- No, I know it's like crazy.
- Yeah, remember "Fall Guys?"
- What?
Oh, people still play "Fall Guys?"
- Do they?
- Yeah, still, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, I-
- I don't think
it's as much of a meme as it was, though.
- Was it even a meme before?
- I mean there were like,
there was like a period
where there were some memes
- Okay.
- varying in hilarity.
- It was like nothing
compared to "Among Us."
- No, no.
- It came out right before "Among Us,"
and it got destroyed by "Among Us."
- [All] Yeah.
- "Among Us," oh my goodness.
- I mean, there's memes still.
- About, yeah.
- "Among Us," it was so-
- I don't even like playing the
game, I just love the memes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Among Us" everywhere.
- So, you've been on YouTube
for 10 plus years, right?
- Yeah.
- Do you have
like a favorite era of YouTube?
- Favorite era?
- When you like-
- Honestly, I like my
"League" parody song days
'cause that shit was fun.
I'm like, yeah, let me...
Everyone wants to do
"League" parody songs.
- Well, I used to like
un-ironically listen
to like "Instalok."
- Yeah!
Well, okay, I mean, they were cute, cool.
- But now when I go back I'm like,
what do they want from this?
- It was like a cool era where everyone
was trying to take songs
and make parody's out of it
to make it fit like "League of Legends"
'cause that's very used parody.
- Right.
- So I would like take like
these weeb songs and like,
"Yeah," like it's really
cringe, obviously.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was fun
'cause I would draw everything myself
and do everything myself.
- Oh that was good (indistinct).
- That was creatively fulfilling for me.
And that was super fun for me.
I liked that-
- And that was a period where the people
still enjoyed "League" as well.
- Yeah, and then oh my God,
do you remember the "League
Cyphers" by any chance?
- Yeah.
- The rapping thingy.
It was really-
- I'm not surprised.
- There's still a really
big scene for anime ciphers.
- Oh my God, someone invite me to one!
I wanna do one.
- I know a bunch of people who would-
- Yeah, I know a bunch
of people who would go.
- I want to do more like-
- Is anime ciphers
still a thing?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- Please, I wanna do more
like anime just like projects.
If you need me to fandub anything
or just like even a
project, I'm desperate.
Like-
- Why are you desperate?
- Give me a role!
- Don't fuckin' say that.
Pretend like you're busy.
- Yeah.
- It's funny 'cause we're-
- Oh, I don't know
if I can fit it in.
- I'm desperate!
- Every anime content creator I know
is trying to get out of anime now.
- Yeah.
- Really?
I kinda miss it.
It's like nostalgic.
I just wanna do cute, silly things again.
Like, whether it's, fuck, I
would even do "Abridged" series.
I don't fucking care, man.
- Oh my God.
- I thought you said a
British series there.
- [Joey and Garnt] A British series.
- "Hey, what's going on?"
- I have a pretty good British accent,
so if you need someone to voice
a British character for you,
let me just drink out
of my bottle of water."
- You sound like a British
person with a concussion.
(Garnt laughs)
- My Supps.
- Had a bit too much
to drink, had a bit too
much GamerSupps to drink.
- Trash Taste in the description.
(Joey laughs)
- You just gave up that.
Like, you just went back to American.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, accents, so
when I audition for stuff,
sometimes they want accents, right?
- [Connor and Garnt] Yeah.
- My biggest like, okay,
when they ask for an
Asian accent (laughs)...
- What does that even mean, though?
- That's what I'm saying!
- What does that even mean?
Do you like the ProZD
video where he's like,
"When they ask me to audition
with an Asian accent,"
have you seen that?
- Oh, I saw that one!
- That's so good.
- Yeah.
- And then like, I feel so racist.
Like, what do you want me to do?
What accent do you want me to possibly...
It's like an amalgamation of like,
Chinese, Korean, Japanese-
- Have you done any reads?
- So, here's a...
They wanted a Japanese accent, right?
- Yeah, and I didn't know how to do it,
so I just winged it for my audition
'cause I mean, I want roles, man.
- Can I hear it?
- No, man.
I don't if I could.
- You made me do American!
- Yeah.
- Well, I'm Japanese all out.
(all laughing)
- I can't, I can't, I can't.
- You get the J pass.
- You get the J pass, you
get the J pass, don't worry.
- It's really awful, I can't!
(all laughing)
But the thing is, I got a
call back for that role.
They're like, "Yeah, we really liked it."
I'm like, what was I saying?
And I'd have to re-listen to my...
I'm like, this is not a Japanese accent.
- I mean, yeah.
What is the accent, really?
- It's just Catacano, right?
It's just pronouncing things in Catacano.
- "Hello, my name is..."
- Yeah, it's like that.
- Mine wasn't
that like, strong.
- That's pretty normal,
though.
- Actually.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just felt weird.
- Well, 'cause it feels
like you're mocking somebody
who's trying their hardest.
- Yeah, and I don't mean
to mock but it's just like what I hear
from like media, like,
other game characters
with accents and I try to emulate those.
- Yeah.
- It's just when they
ask for an Asian accent,
it's always like...
I'm like, put on the spot.
I'm like, what do you want me to do?
- That's a red flag though,
when it's like Asian.
- It shouldn't be an Asian accent.
- There's a lotta countries
in Asia.
- I feel like-
- Like, be more specific!
- That's it.
- Right? Like, what if I ask you to do-
- [Joey] Indian is technically Asian.
- Yeah, like what if I ask
you to do a European accent?
Like, what is
a European accent?
- What is that?
I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah,
even when they say like,
American or British.
It's like, well, you can have-
- There's a lot of those.
- Yeah, you have to be
very specific on this one.
- It's just like, you just do what
you think is right and then
if they like it, they like it.
If they don't like it...
It is what it is.
- Can you do a Korean accent?
- Oh.
I just feel so bad doing it.
Like, I don't mean to
make fun of anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's just me,
really trying but I feel like people
will take it the wrong way,
so I'm deathly scared of-
- Oh, I've done
some fucked up shit.
- But, you never know, like
someone fucking clips it,
Twitter, like...
- That's true, that's true.
- Like-
- You're a veteran,
you can tell.
- Yeah.
- But that's okay.
- But like,
aren't you Korean as well?
So-
- I am Korean, yes.
- So (laughs)-
- So you're allowed.
- It's fine.
- (laughs) Surely,
surely if you're Korean,
- Yeah, surely you're allowed,
right?
- You're allowed
to attempt a Korean accent.
- All the viewers know
this but I've done like,
I voiced like an African in a game
and that was not my proudest moment,
but that was in a game.
- That's my favorite one.
- Right, right.
- Everyone loves it 'cause literally,
like before the Uganda Knuckles meme,
and it was literally that accent.
- Yeah.
- Oh!
- But then like,
they selected me for some fuckin' reason.
- Sometimes they,
- Awful, awful.
- you never know what they select you for.
It could be the way that you
say certain things or like...
It's so-
- But it was weird.
'Cause when you started
voice acting, right?
Like, that wasn't like a thing yet
where everyone was like,
"You can't do this voice if you're not
that kind of-
- Ethnicity.
- Well, these days they want like-
- Yeah, now you have to.
- If it's an Asian character,
they want an Asian character.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're very like-
- 'Cause "League" changed a lot
of the voice actors like very secretly.
- Really?
- On some of the characters.
- Yeah, wasn't Lucian voiced by-
- Yeah, Patrick Seitz.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, Lucian was actually the same person
and it's a white guy, Patrick Seitz.
He's done like so many,
he's an amazing voice actor.
- Wait, I know Patrick Seitz.
He's really good.
- He's amazing.
But yeah, they very
quietly changed his voice
in the game into-
- Oh, very interesting.
Wow, that's interesting.
- Because it was weird.
Like, I remember, like obviously the,
when they all started changing and it kind
of just changed overnight.
Like, everyone was
like, that's not normal.
- Like, was it the
ethnicity issue or what?
- Yeah, well, I mean, a lot of the,
now it's like, all right, well, obviously,
and it makes sense.
Obviously a Black person
should play a Black person.
- Right.
- And a white person should
probably play a white person,
I don't fuckin' know.
I don't care.
I just audition for the thing now.
- I just audition for it,
if you like it, take it.
- I'm just trying to like,
avoid the mind field.
I'm like, am I good?
I'm good? Okay, I'm good.
- Yeah, yeah.
Sometimes I'm like,
what if something I say
gets clipped out of context, put online,
and then I wake up and there's
8,000 notifications like,
"Lily, did you see?"
That's my nightmare.
- Yeah.
- I mean, that's like the 10 years worth
of like streaming experience.
Like, I need to be careful
- I'm sorry, I-
- about everything I say.
- The PTSD.
- I probably sound really like-
- The PTSD, huh?
- Yeah.
- I think if your intent is very clear,
it won't happen.
- I do try to make,
like, super like this is
who I am, blah, blah, blah.
- Yeah.
- Thank God we cut
that stuff she said
earlier, it was so crazy.
- No, because like luckily we're
on a podcast so like,
even we can like edit it.
But like as a Twitch streamer
being online so much,
like I'm scared.
I'm scared like, I
would let something slip
or something would get
taken out of context.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it could be
totally like unintentional or
like, a mistake or whatever,
but that moment could like,
define a lot of things.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you just, just don't do it, Forehead.
(Garnt laughs)
- Just get good, just get good.
- Just be careful.
(all laughing)
- Wow, it's that easy.
- Yeah, wow.
- Did Michael message you?
- I'm really excited
for you to talk to Michael.
- I hope you guys talk about boxing.
I know we didn't
get to the boxing.
- Yeah, I obviously
wanna talk to him about it.
- But like, he looked so fucking cool.
I watched that video of him
boxing like three times.
It was so...
I think the fact that
there was a creator clash
with like everyone who really
gave it their all changed at once.
- It was like, really good vibes.
- That's insane.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow, would you guys ever box each other
like Anituber versus, no?
No?
- I mean, I don't know.
- Sure.
- You're like-
- I could see you box
and get beat up.
- Yeah,
I went to a boxing class
with Ludwig the other day.
- Oh, is it for the thing?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Are you gonna do it?
- Possibly.
Yeah, maybe, we'll see.
- You should do it.
I think you should do it.
- I kinda wanna,
I don't know though, we'll see, we'll see.
- Yeah.
- Who the fuck's gonna teach
me in Japan how to box?
- Oh, right, you are not from here.
- No, yeah.
- I'm sure there's boxing gyms
you can go to.
- Maybe, I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Are we recording by the way?
- Yeah, we are.
- Oh, okay, sorry.
I thought we were just having small talk.
I didn't realize you re-pressed
the record button.
- Yeah, it's recording.
We're recording.
- Okay, okay.
- Boxing, yeah.
- Are you gonna box?
- Dude, I'm too self conscious.
When they-
- Well, you look like shit
when you box 'cause you're fuckin',
you get sweaty, you get punched.
- Michael looked cooler.
- No one looks
like a model when they box.
- Yeah.
- Well, some of the people
look kind of cool, like
their forearms and stuff.
Like, the whole dodging, weaving,
like I thought that was really cool,
but they also slather your face
with the Vaseline before,
like their faces are really shiny.
- Yeah.
- To prevent cuts and stuff.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah, I was wondering
why their faces were shiny.
- I just do that anyway.
- Oh, oh, okay.
- Every morning he's just...
- Every morning just
Vaseline on your face.
- I'm just really into like...
Yeah, dude, like "American Psycho."
- Yeah, just peelin' it off, right?
- Just peelin' it off.
Ready.
- What was it like watching Michael
live during Creator Clash?
- I was screaming.
I was so excited and happy.
I was like, "Yeah, that's my boyfriend!"
I was like in discord with
like, six other friends watching
the same thing and we were
just like screaming for...
Energy was great.
It was good.
- Oh, yeah.
- Was it nerve wracking?
Because like, I mean, you're
watching your partner box,
so, I'd be fuckin' scared.
- Of course.
I was scared he was gonna
get like hit in the head
and then what if he just gets
a concussion and dies or something?
I don't know, there's a real fear of that.
Head injuries are terrible.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- On hit and you can literally like,
get brain damage and stuff.
- Yeah.
- So, I was scared of that,
but then as soon as I
saw his form and stuff,
I'm like, yeah.
- Yeah, he knows.
He's good, he's good.
He's really good.
- Yeah.
Especially like out of a lot of people,
he just seemed like he
took to it so naturally.
- Yeah.
- He's the type of person
where if he wants to learn
something, he will learn it.
- Right.
- He will put
it with all.
So, I was very impressed.
But you were gonna talk
about that with him,
and-
- We'll talk about
it with him as well.
- Yeah.
- Oh, am I allowed to like,
wait, is this like separate?
Am I coming out first
and then he's coming on?
- Yep, you're coming on first.
- So, am I spoiling the
guests for the next-
- Yeah, no.
- You can spoil anything.
- So, spoilers, Michael Reeves' next.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(all laughing)
- You guys should definitely talk
to him about anime and British food.
- I'm excited 'cause I'm gonna be,
like not the British.
It's gonna be Michael versus these two.
- I know one of the shows he loves,
so I'm excited to talk to him about it.
- Yeah.
- He loves what?
- He loves "Banana Fish."
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, I thought you
were about to say "Arcane."
(all laughing)
- I was like, God help me!
- Can we talk to him about "Arcane?"
- He loves "Arcane."
- Let's fucking go!
- Let's go!
- [Connor and Garnt] Let's go!
- Oh my God.
- So, he's a human being?
- Yeah.
- Everyone loves "Arcane."
- A sheep.
- At this point he's not
watching it out of spite.
- That's really-
- Yeah, that's why it's funny.
- That's his thing.
- Oh, oh.
- Yeah.
- That's what I love to do.
- It's been going on so long now.
- Oh.
- Yeah, wow.
- It's so funny where I just gotta-
- You're depriving yourself of one
of the greatest TV shows out
of all time out of spite.
- Yeah.
- Thanks, what can I say?
I'm a Cancer.
(all laughing)
- Okay, all right.
Okay.
- Yeah.
- Well, guys, thank you
so much for watching
the "Trash Taste Podcast,"
episode number...
- I don't know, 10...
- Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] But it's 106 B.
- Yeah, 106 B.
- Yeah, it's probably 106,
probably not because we're-
- Episode number 106.
- Insert the-
- 107, 108.
- Use one of those.
(all laughing)
- And if you liked this,
make sure to check out the description
for these GamerSupps bottles,
code Trash Taste for
10% off, I don't know.
Is it 10%?
It's probably something like that, right?
- Something like that.
- Yeah, and-
- Do you wanna shout
out our patrons as well?
- Patrons? Like Patreon?
- [Guys] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Look at all these names.
Look at all these names.
- They're on screen right now.
- Look at all these names
that are on screen right now.
- Oh my God,
thank you so much for contributing.
Wow.
(all laughing)
- Wow.
Wow!
- I can't wait to come on your show
and then just-
- Yeah, just do
the exact same thing.
- Just behave like a little shit.
- Hey, guys, welcome to
the "Offline TV Podcast."
- Yeah, well thank you so,
make sure, hit a Subscribe.
Give us a comment.
What was your favorite
topic on today's podcast
and who do you wanna see next?
- Should Joey watch "Arcane?"
- And should Connor box?
- Oh, yeah, all these days-
- So many questions to answer.
- I know, yeah.
- There's so many.
- What are you gonna do?
- But of course, as well,
check out Lily's stuff.
Link's in the description below.
- Yeah, check out LilyPichu on Spotify.
Get me those stream plays.
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah.
- Get that extra 0.01 cents.
- Not even, man.
- Not even.
- 0.00...
- Yeah.
- It's like that little for like one play.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, it's ridiculous.
But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
go to our Patreon, patreon.com/trashtaste,
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah,
thanks for coming, Lily.
- Wow,
that was really professional.
Good job today.
- Yeah, thank you, thank you.
- That's why we leave the outros to him.
- Yeah, I've been doin'
'em every week.
- That's really good.
- I don't try to touch it, yeah.
I don't even know what I'm even saying.
- If he's not here I'm just like,
I don't know what to
fuckin' say. (all laughing)
- How do we end the show? (all laughing)
- Bye.
- [Guys] Bye!
(mellow music)
(singer vocalizing)